et on est en live
magnifique
tu me diras ce ton côté tu vois le
chantre qui se passe sur le stream
oui il ya eu main il ya marqué regardez
maintenant avec funk spectateurs
exactement aabar ya déjà des gens à des
gens ils sont chauds sa lutte au max
locomotive installe-toi tranquillement
et bastien comme d'habitude cobayes
thomas que le premier arrivé à chaque
fois tu vas me dire si tu entends c'est
tu entends nicolas qui est avec nous
bonsoir
moi fait cool
hop là
tout est bon pour le son tour tandis
qu'au incroyable incroyable pour ba
écoute installe-toi tranquillement comme
je dis bon soir au 10 rue neuve
spectateurs qui sont là c'est faux si
vous êtes hyper actif les gars et
mesdames peut-être cela sinon
effectivement aucune discrimination ne
sera accepté installez-vous
tranquillement on va se laisser cinq six
petites minutes et puis après on
présentera notre notre invité pions
on donnera le sommaire le sommaire du
soir alors que juste que je modifie le
titre du stream parce que je suis un
amateur
on parle pas du tout de travaux qui
laisse comme c'est écrit là
hop là
toi nico côte est où tout est bon dit tu
vois tu vois les gens qui étaient dans
le chat un petit peu
les côtes ils disent tu m'entends
alors peut-être déjà les premiers
problèmes techniques non
problèmes techniques du coup non mais
pour ça
alors peut-être déjà les premiers
problèmes techniques qui vieillit coup
n'en est pour ça
alors peut-être déjà eu des problèmes
techniques qui fait d'accord n'ont pas
non pour ceux qui viennent d'arriver ne
partez pas ne vous enfuyez pas c'est
juste moi qui sait pas gérer mais est qu
est ce que nico tu m'entends toujours ou
pas
je crois que mme ute
alors je me dis fils a ici on en
attendait dehors
est ce que j'ai à l'eau ouais tu
m'entends
allô allô allô allô
ah merde bon bah écoutez si vous êtes
arrivé sur le sur le stream l'icône
m'entend pas du tout donc ça c'est
merveilleux
scurko ne vous inquiétez pas ça va aller
well as tu m'entends pas ouais ouais on
a eu notre premier problème technique
t'en fais pas c'est normal bienvenue sur
vérins qui l'on veut
révéler aucun problème pour faire un
très beau coup
la balle et 7 des loups du coup si vous
entendez nico maintenant qu'il est
revenue qu'il est venu avec nous
ouais tu étais moto max mamers et merci
de pas être partie malgré malgré les
couples créer des problèmes techniques
ok up
genre ça en même temps
bonsoir à tous ce carré saluer nous en
entendons machine géniale shenzhen
génial et je la sens encore une deux
minutes et puis et puis on se fait le
petit démarrage installez-vous lancé
lancé le site envergure garder petite
nouveauté cible il avait raté on sait
jamais et puis je vous donne tout ça
donc
eh ben on est parti dès à des problèmes
de son incroyable à salut romain comment
tu vas
supervisera les gens y superviser la
raison son travail après
l'autre des formations professionnelles
on a cours au qui nous dit que r10 bared
tu es nul alors
je sais pas moi je trouve que c'est
plutôt un bon joueur mais tu peux des
bars états unis si tu peux donner de
l'amour tu peut déverser ta haine mes
toiles escourrou
bombe à ce qui paraît à nico ya que toi
qui est supervisée à moi de mon côté
j'ai une totale confiance donc c'est
bien
j'ai l'impression du goût là
bon allez on est parti bonsoir bonsoir à
tous j'espère que vous allez bien
bienvenue pour ce nouveau stream du coup
envergure comme vous le voyez dans le
titre du stream ce soir on va regarder
du film de deux joueurs de pro spectre
est attendu spécialiste du tiers en
théorie on nous parle de max christie et
patrick pas de veine junior et pour ça
je suis accompagné du meilleur dans ce
domaine on est avec nicolas lang comment
tu vois
ça va bien et toi merci quand j'ai
entendu parler de meilleur je pensais
que texter curie mais du coup c'est ce
que moi au final
c'est bien tu te diminue la pression
avant tu vois pas tu as raison c'est une
bonne technique c'est une bonne
technique alors on va te présenter
rapidement pour les gens qui te qui te
connaissent pas tu es un joueur
professionnel qui joue du coup dans le
championnat dans le championnat français
en première division nôtre actuellement
betclic et l'ict il y bien suivi tous
les changements de nom est tu joues pour
le csp limoges noté le capitaine c'est
bien ça
exactement ça ouais et du coup tu es
considéré de façon de façon assez assez
homogène comme un joueur qui est
spécialisée dans une sorte et pas qu'un
shooter mais était réputé pour ton tir
est ce que tu peux nous rapidement nous
faire un petit un petit point sur ton
sur ton parcours sur les dernières
années et comment comment tu te sens
actuellement notre ton club
webb a pas de soucis moi je veux pas et
je vais pas tout reprendre depuis le
début mai sur les on va dire sur les
trois derniers clubs j'ai fait j'ai fait
trois ans l'asvel une année à la sic
strasbourg
avant chrome arrive et
circuits ouais je suis parti un peu
avant mais il fallait fallait partir
avant qu'on en arrive vite et
depuis je suis avec ma troisième année
que je suis à limoges
voilà ça se passe ça se passe très bien
pour moi et oui comme tu disais je suis
quand même je suis quand même réputé
pour mon pour mon tir donc
des fois après c'est pareil pour tous
les shooteurs est des soirs avec des
sources en mai il ya là la consistance
dans le travail avec la même chance
ouais mais effectivement donc comme tu
le dis c'est qu'on sente comme qui peut
qui peut varier justement on appris de
profil un peu un peu particulier ce soir
parce que deux joueurs très réputé comme
le disait pour le pour le tir extérieur
et qui cette année ont des galères
alors pour différentes raisons c'est ce
qu'on va regarder mon décalage dans leur
réussite
toi ça t'est arrivé d'avoir des trous
d'adressent assez conséquents sur une
saison complète c'est plus des choses
qui vont être assez épisodique
généralement ton côté ben oui oui quand
j'étais plus jeune bâle a en plus ça
m'étonne pas parce qu'on parle de
brasles de jeunes joueurs et je pense
que c'est avec l'expérience que tu
arrives à temps d'une saison tu auras
des périodes de moins bien c'est sûr
mais essayer de les raccourcir le plus
possible et de rebondir le plus vite
possible et c'est pas simple mais je
pense que ça passe avant tout par voilà
des fois un peu un peu lâché prise on va
dire et quand tu es jeune tu as envie de
réussir notamment sur des joueurs comme
ça qui voilà qui je pense qu'ils ont ils
ont la draft en ligne de mire et tu te
mets beaucoup de pression et des fois
plus tu loupes à un lâcher prise c'est
facile à dire c'est plus dur à faire et
je pense que c'est des fois avec
l'expérience que tu apprends un peu
mieux avant le bonne mentalité pour
rebondir plus rapidement
ok je sais ce que je fais ce que tu veux
dire
d'ailleurs parce qu'on en parle depuis
tout à l'heure de des spécialistes du
tir de shooter et c'est
là ce soir on va regarder deux tireurs
que je qualifierais de shooter différent
il ya plusieurs rôles dans le tir on en
a déjà parlé plusieurs fois chez en
verdure on a les joueurs qui vont être
plus à l'aise en sortie de dribble et
des joueurs qui vont être plus à l'aise
et du catch and shoot pur et dur à des
gens qui vont au delà les eaux du camp
du déplacement à travers les écrans toi
est-ce que tu ferais deux catégories
comment est-ce que tu définirais
s'étiola et puis surtout est-ce que
c'est assez évident à ce que c'est assez
régulier pour un tweeter de passer d'un
certain rôle d'un certain type de deux
prises de tir à un autre ou c'est
quelque chose qui est très compliqué
non je pense que déjà il ya que tu sais
faire en tant qu' en tant que chanteur
mais il ya aussi comment le hockey le
système d utiliser est ce que tu vas
beaucoup sortir des écrans est ce que le
coach va va s'appuyer sur ta qualité de
shoot quoi là pour m'aider système en
place pour toi qui vont aussi mourir
d'autres choses pour les autres ou alors
tu as le talent et shooter qui est
vraiment que là pour être à l'opposé
notamment sur les pick and roll et du
coup comme comme il est à l'opposé la
défense va moins à les aider et voilà
des fois tu te tu te sacrifies un peu
parce que la défense va pas aider tu vas
pouvoir forcément avoir de shoot mais
rien que sa présence va faire que sur le
pick and roll ça va ouvrir des espaces
pour pour le big men qui roule ou art le
meneur ou l'arrière qui joua qui joue le
pic
est par exemple si tant est un jeune
joueur qui a connu des situations y
avait beaucoup la balle en main on sait
que les joueurs américains au niveau
lycée r ce sont les grosses stars de
leur équipe et sont à peu près à peu
près
responsable de toute la création fête du
jeu un joueur qui est un gros show
autour de volume du coup dans le dribble
et caetera et qui passent d'un coup en
tant que je tort de jeter hors des
retards les écrans jouteurs de fin de
chaîne en termes d'habitudes motrices
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui peut
rapidement se mettre en place ou tu as
quand même
pas comme je travaille à faire ou des
fois c'est un obstacle trop difficile à
passer
non je pense que c'est clair et net que
tu as besoin d'une d'une certaine
période d'adaptation
tu sais quand tu es habitué d'un côté
jeunes à avoir la balle en main a
toujours être en rythme quand tu passes
en tant que shooter est à quelqu'un
d'autre peut-être tu as quelqu'un
d'autre qui a beaucoup la balle en main
et un peu tributaire de ça voilà une
action tu vas avoir un choix tout seul
mais après pendant des x 3 4 minutes tu
vois que tu vas courir sans toucher la
balle et ben c'est c'est dur de se
mettre en route surtout quand tu as déjà
eu l'habitude quand tu étais plus jeune
de toujours avoir la balle en main quand
tu vois ça tu es bon tu sais ce que tu
as ta carrière de passer justement d'un
rôle de tirera d'autres rouler comme moi
ce que tu as tu as fait pour s'adapter
et développer ça est-ce que c'est
beaucoup de répétitions d'entraînement
c'est vraiment plus psychologique
c'est un peu un peu tout ça à la fois je
pense c'est clair et net que moi quand
j'étais en la jeune quand j'étais cadet
et des espoirs à châlons bat j'avais
beaucoup beaucoup la balle en main après
quand tu passes en pro il faut il faut
trouver ton faut trouver ton rôle qu'ils
jouent avec des chances de jouer avec
des forts joueurs donc t'as pas moins la
balle faut trouver ton rôle quand tu
vises un tu es grosse d'equipe c'est sûr
que ta ta ta mwen la balle en main
maintenant ou même moins deux systèmes
pour toi là ça fait deux ans maintenant
que j'ai quand même beaucoup plus la
balle en main où beaucoup de plus de
deux systèmes pour moi et c'est sûr et
c'est clair et net que c'est beaucoup
plus facile de se mettre en route
tu sais que si tu loupes ce shoot là
c'est pas fortement la fin du monde
parce que dans deux trois actions bat en
aura d'autres dans des équipes où tu
partages le temps de jeu et qu'il ya
plus de plus de roster et ben si tu
loupes à un ou deux shoots battue peut
très bien aller sur le banc pendant
pendant 10 2 minutes et c'est beaucoup
plus dur de se mettre en route
je fais ce que tu veux dire moi
personnellement quand je quand je jouais
déjà je prenais pas de tiers parce que
c'était arrêté à chaque fois et le si
l'on prenait enchanté directement du
doigt ce que tu veux dire autant de
pression que tu peux avoir coté sur un
plus petit volume
là ce soir on va regarder pas mal de
clips de c2c de ces gars-là de ces deux
jeunes là toi quand tu va regarder un
jeune arrive et dont on exclut la balle
entraînements ou bien que tu vas faire
du film contre une équipe adverse par
exemple et que tu dois analyser un
shooter que tu allais était un tir sur
quoi tu vas être vigilant
alors déjà bon c'est sûr elle avait la
position des mains des choses comme
savoir s'il ya pas de tir le lire les
histoires de shooter avec la paume fin
est pas obligé de tout est vraiment que
avec le bout des doigts mais s'est
trouvé une
juste mesure on va dire
moi
c'est un peu la coordination
ça veut dire souvent tu dis aux jeunes
joueurs maintenant mais des gens de
shoot avec les jambes ou tu as
l'impression qu'ils confondent un peu
tout ça veut dire que soyez m ils font
une espèce de squatter après il monte il
monte les jambes et il lâche la balle
après vous soyez montre très vite la
balle au dessus de la tête mais
descendre les jambes après donc si tu
vas y à vraiment un
un guide et fois un gros problème de
coordination et des fois je sais que moi
j'ai la chance d'avoir mon père qui m'a
toujours interdit de monter la balle au
dessus de la tête tant que j'avais pas
la force nécessaire et je sais que votre
côté jeune tu veux un peu recopier ce
qui se passe à la télé
c'est sûr que michael jordan il a jamais
tiré avec la balle au niveau de la
poitrine quoi donc tu essayes un peu de
copier mais sauf que tata 11 12 13 13
ans je vois aussi sur mes camps de
basket et
ça veut ça veut un peu tout faire trop
vite et tu prendre vraiment des
mauvaises habitudes qui derrière son
très dur à très dur enlevé maintien en
profitant on va pourrir là dessus il
n'ya pas très longtemps les copains la
lise tourner un une émission est menée
sur la draft de 2017 et il parlait des
joueurs comme marque alfa tct pas donc
qu'ils avaient vous connaissez tard et
vous avez détruit leurs tirs pour
essayer de leur faire et que ça pouvait
arriver à des blessures c'est vraiment
quelque chose de difficile de changer un
tir et qui peut tu risques et surtout à
haut niveau quand tu arrives à 19 20 ans
dans un monde professionnel nba
après là mais l'amélioré je pense que
que c'est toujours possible moi je vois
des vidéos de deux mois deux mois
actuellement ou mois à 22 23 ans et
c'est pas le même tir je l'écris j'ai
clairement est clairement améliorée mais
au final la base reste la même même
quand je vois quand je vois des vidéos
de kobe à 18 ans où kobe à 30 ans c'est
tu vois que la base paris reste la même
et il ya où c'est tout c'est un peu
perfectionner quoi même steve curie 1 je
trouve ces mois là je vois que c'est pas
le pas le sait pas exactement le même
chose que quand il est arrivé quand il
est arrivé en nba quoi donc
oui tu peux tu peux changer quelques
détails tu peux un peu peaufiner
améliorée par contre pour produire de a
à z c'est quand même très compliqué
c'est moi je dis que c'est quand même
très dangereux quoi ta stadt à jouer au
basket à l'est quand ils arrivent en nba
ça fait bien dix ans qui a les 10 15 ans
qui joue au basket si tutu change ça
veut dire quand même des milliers et des
milliers de shoot
fois tu vois tu vas faire un sacré
chantier quoi
ok bah ouais ce qui pourrait expliquer
entre autres la blessure de marque alfa
on sait que halak a taquiné audi dans
les commentaires de mandat fut
effectivement il s'en est jamais remise
et péter des po aix ancienne blessure
sur blessure il encore blessé orlando il
ya des mecs parfois qui arrive je sais
pas si tu avais vu du lot au bol je peux
pas te mettre deux cols mais on the ball
qui est passé d'un geste très casse est
un excellent tireur à trois points
est-ce que c'est plus à l'adaptation de
mécanique sur des petits détails des
habitudes motrices ou est ce que c'est
une refonte en tire
moi je sais pas je suis pas assez bon
toi tu as usual je pense que c'est un
ouais j'avais j'avais vu après tu sais y
est aussi une autre paramètre c'est la
tête ça veut dire que les gars il on
sait que des gars qui sont un peu drafté
au monde ce que de parler de leurs tirs
toute la journée
barbie dames enfin mais moi je sais pas
comment je réagirais si l'on fait que te
parle et on tire toute la journée et
chaque fois que tu changes un champ
jamais ni détails à l'entraînement de
films à l'entraînement on se fout de ta
gueule soit tu vois
c'est quand même des jeunes joueurs ou à
la base en plus ils sont pas forcément à
l'aise avec ça
et là bas tout le monde est focalisé que
là dessus
tu vois même que tu vois un gars comme
dan simmons l'été et n ya pas de
pression rien son geste je trouve il
n'est pas idée pas idée pas trop mal tu
ris et c'est plutôt fluide et après ils
arrivent à faire des saisons où ils
entendent même pas pendant pendant
quarante cinq matches quoi donc ça c'est
quand même la tête c'est pour moi c'est
vraiment aussi important que le que le
geste web et simons qui avait séance
hämmerli quelques tirs et plus on se
rappelle que ça avait fait des
célébrations un peu un peu ridicule de
ses coéquipiers qui se jeter tous par
terre parce qu'il avait mis un premier
tir à trois points et c'est donc oui si
tu sentais une pression pression est
énorme tout le temps t'as pas envie de
les prendre surtout dans une ligne ou
maintenant les pourcentages sont au
dessus de tout et que des joueurs des
foires refuge tu sais en fin de
possession de prendre un tir propre à
baisser leur pourcentage donc on est un
peu de ne pas une parodie là dessus
nous tu vois on se dit souvent qu'en
regard de des jeunes et qu'on essaie de
faire une projection pour le futur skis
pour attirer dans une bille et est ce
que le soutien sera fait à brocade
plusieurs indicateurs on regarde le
volume comme tu dis fuck un volume assez
suffisant pour pour avoir une projection
derrière on va regarder le pourcentage
souvent lancers francs qui pour nous est
un bon indicateur et on va regarder
enfin le la distance à laquelle il prend
des heures parce qu'on sait qu'en nba tu
va reculer d'un bon pas par rapport à la
ligne n 6 et et le la vitesse
d'exécution
est ce que le tir par rapidement pas
pour pouvoir justement être une arme
suffisante est ce que toi cet indicateur
qui te semble intéressant où il ya des
choses que l'on pleut ce jour ses
frontières à modifier ou le volume ou la
distance etc est ce qu'il ya des choses
auxquelles on pense pas et que toi tu
vas lui pas mal
ben tu vois déjà les lancers francs je
pense avant ça dépend aussi qu'on
m'attend tires
tu vois je sais pas c'est un tir 2 j'ai
déjà fait des saisons ou lancer je pense
que j'étais pas au top parce que parce
que j'en tirerai pas beaucoup aidé cta
injectant loupé un bâti retentir quatre
ans quatre en quatre matches tolou
peintes et évite à 75% quoi
mais hélas pour l'histoire la distance
moi je sais que la première fois que
j'avais joué sur un terrain terrain nba
ça m'a vraiment marqué la distance de la
ligne comme semblait très très très loin
et mais c'était même avant que la star
2010 était même avant que la ligne en
europe passe à la distance actuel et
même quand elle est passée en europe à
10 ans actuel j'ai j'avais l'impression
que c'était loin déjà mais au final je
pense que en fait
tu t'habitues à tout en fait donc même
des gars comme ça qu'ils foutent sur la
ligne le rabbinat trois points quand ils
passent après en nba peut-être qu'il y
aura un petit temps d'adaptation mais au
final je pense que c'est quand même que
des gars qui sont quand même des
athlètes
je pense que la distance ne sera pas
forcément le gros souci après bien sûr
c'est à des gros un gros des gros
défauts techniques déjà une distance
comme ça t'as déjà du mal à être
régulier et quand tu passes derrière ça
peut saper sable ça peut être compliqué
comme ici si les bases sont plutôt
propre
même si les gages sont pas forcément de
très très loin en acier le jour où ils
passeront à une biche que j'ai pas de
doute qu'il est y réussiront à s'adapter
non pour toi alors on va être dans la
phase ascendante des extrêmes est un mec
qui prend énormément de pula pas
mi-distance n'ont pas de club de tir à
mi-distance chanter deux points le long
mais qui prend pas un trois points tu
pourras tu pourrais te crois dans un
développement tiers par la suite si ce
volume la teinte est récent si la
mécanique allait en place et ciel et
régularité
ouais ouais surtout qu'il ya tu passes
en nba je pense surtout sur des
profils comme ça un tat une armée de
coach qui vient pour travailler que toi
donc il n'y a pas de raison que tu
arrives pas
ajouter ça à ton jeu surtout comme on
lisait si les débats sont plutôt bonnes
à la basque
après écoute très très bien on va
pouvoir du coup maintenant passer à nos
deux cas de cas individuels alors
normalement tu vas voir est-ce que je
commence à peu à peu près à maîtriser en
théorie si je fais ça
hop là toi depuis ton retour tu devrais
pouvoir avoir le site envergure sous les
yeux de sa magnifique site en toute
objectivité
moralement maintenant tu as été mon moi
tu es bon ouais tu vois c'est vous alors
tu veux pas dire que tu accuses alizon
il n'ose pas me dire ils sont trop
gentils avec moi j'ai mis une taille
normalement assez assez grosse pour que
des vieilles personnes comme moi arrive
à lire sans se détruire les yeux parce
que pour toi niveau destin de savas ulu
tu es vraiment très très vive voix non
moi ça devrait ça devrait le faire ça
devrait le faire ok alors on est sur le
premier joueur on va parler ce soir
c'est max christie qui est un vous voyez
donc justin garde assez assez classique
tu sais moi on est dans une ligue nba où
on aime bien avoir des positions laisse
donc des joueurs qui sont pas forcément
définis par leur poste max christie
devrait être par son jeu en arrière pur
et dur vraiment un deuxième arrière
shooteur ont néanmoins su ration sicsic
190 86 m on a un point de 86 tullow même
s'il a un peu pris depuis le début de
l'année j'avais pu voir il joue du côté
de michigan state donc michigan 7 c'est
une équipe de hi-media
donc une déficit plus grosses
conférences du pays sous les ordres de
tommy iso qui est devenu un coach
légendaire
voilà et c'est un programme cette année
qui il fait des résultats plutôt
intéressant avec beaucoup de vétérans il
est entouré de deux jours très âgées
parfois des 5e année tu sens une scie et
normalement on fait quatre ans mais à
cause de la pandémie ils ont pu avoir
une nouvelle année d'éligibilité
pour jouer une cinquième année donc tu
as des mecs à ses côtés qui sont
vraiment expérimenté qui ont 4 5 ans de
plus que lui
on la 31e de notre big board il était
attendu dans le top 20 est ce qui
explique qu'ils sont un peu descendu et
que les observateurs génèral de sont un
petit peu c'est la réussite aux tirs à
trois points alors pour ceux qui
connaissent pas son parcours aux lycéens
c'était un des plus gros de serrures au
niveau inférieur qui avaient des très
bons pourcentages
on s'attendait à ce qu'une belle
régularité et là cette année du côté du
michigan c'est de vous le voyez ici on
est sur 34 % à 3 points ce qui est
intéressant ce qui est correct mais ce
qui est pas élite haut niveau n 6 est
surtout pour un joueur aussi réputés que
lui au départ avec un volume pour 30
minutes par match dont trois quarts du
match à 4,3 tentatives
pour les gens aux thermes marins que là
quand tu vois les retrouver le chiffre
en termes de volume à trois points est
ce que ça te permet déjà d'avoir une
idée sur un joueur ou tu trouves que
c'est encore pas suffisant ou bien
justement de sauf que c'est suffisamment
le lardin c'est largement suffisant pour
avoir une estimation 4/3 demande un
match
non pressée dépend toujours du contexte
paraît dépend toujours
comme comme dis de la façon dont
laquelle dans laquelle tu as utilisé si
tu dis qu'il ya beaucoup de deux
dernières années avec lui ben c'était
pas forcément option numéro un
je pense que voilà 4 4 3 3 par match qui
m'a dit qu'il était première année ça
exactement il est fraîche panneaux tu
vois donc c'est tu arrives tu es pas
forcément
avant que c'est vraiment une énorme
énorme star je pense que tu arrives dans
un groupe de vétérans il faut aussi soit
aussi se faire sa place calcul trois
shoots à trois points par match ça me
semble déjà se sentent déjà correct
après même 34%
bah tu vois tu peux tu peux prendre de
façon à inciter à 34% et pourtant c'est
une bonne saison on va c'est un peu
compliqué mais si on va dire tu étais un
peu de thym peu dans le dur tu as une
période d'adaptation en tant que
première année et à 34% tu peux aussi
dire que que voilà tu as des tatas un
potentiel qui est plus intéressant quoi
yes alors effectivement lui pour
l'instant il est assez déçu de sa saison
il est
il est en première année avec pas mal de
vétérans là on est passé sur un site qui
s'appelle matt jeu qui nous permet
d'avoir en gros films alors les habitués
du chat le connaître ou bien d'ailleurs
obtus vous écris une commande parce que
ça fait trois mois que je vous dis je le
fais normalement je les fais voilà
incroyable donc là vous avez les liens
si vous voulez nous suivre en même temps
sur le site et et l'utiliser donc ce
site il nous permet d'avoir la
répartition des tirs d'un joueur donc là
par exemple on voit ces tirs près du
panier on voit les longs de points ici
et on voit pendant de la ici le lion de
points le nombre de constructeurs de
point pris est ici sont une pourcentage
de tirs à trois points pris donc max
cousty il est on le voit la moitié de
ces tirs au niveau de la ligne à trois
points et ensuite beaucoup de tirs à 2
points l'on est finalement très très peu
de tirs près du panier à côté à chaque
fois vous avez la réussite dans chaque
secteur donc là vous avez vous voyez
qu'il est à 45 5% près du panier on
comparera ce avec la deuxième ressource
mais c'est assez faible vous avez 45 %
aujourd'hui l'on de points donc ça c'est
intéressant je trouve est donc
effectivement on est là on a le 34
points à 3 points et enfin la dernière
information que vous donne au mathis et
est ce que le tir réussi est pris
avec ou non une passe décisive donc pour
ce jour là on voit que quand ils shoot à
trois points c'est quasi exclusivement
du catch and shoot donc c'est un joueur
de qui va sortir d'un bonobo coup
d'écran qui va prendre pas mal de tirs à
trois points sur de la transition où il
va être vraiment dans la course
j'attrape et je déclenche et on voit
enfin que c'est un joueur qui quand il
prend peu de tirs près du panier et même
quand il va au cercle on voit ici
génèrent peu de peu de lancers francs où
tu demander n'est-ce pas tu ne dises est
alors que l'indicateur lancers francs il
était vite biaisé par le nombre de
lancers francs tentés on est un gars qui
prend deux lancers francs par un match
donc effectivement on n'est pas sur un
énorme volume mais il ya une belle
réussite à 82% par contre tu nous disais
vétérans donc va beaucoup de vétérans
donc forcément un joueur qui va devoir
s'imposer lui dans une équipe avec ici
donc get by one qui est senior mark
bingham qui est senior edge et aux
gardes qui est plus de plus de jouer aux
heures qui est seigneur lui il est quand
même le deuxième volume de terre de
l'équipe donc c'est un joueur qui donne
la confiance au niveau de son coach
toi c'est sur quatre soirées c'est clair
c'est clair que tu as a confirmé un peu
ce qu'on disait sur les 4,3 ou se
demander si c'était beaucoup pas
beaucoup
c'était dans une équipe où quand même il
ya plusieurs joueurs et donc
la répartition elle est plutôt aller
l'ol plutôt bien équilibré et 4 3 3
points dans une équipe où ça tourne
basse et sait déjà c'est déjà sympa
qu'on ouais c'est clair moi c'est vrai
que le début de l'année alors pour que
le goal 4 2 puis un peu de temps de
monsieur tom izzo le coach il aime
beaucoup responsabiliser ses anciens il
a de très bons liens avec avec ses peurs
que la semaine et il essaie toujours de
trouver un jeune une petite pépite qui
qui met en avant pour rester un
programme attractif pour les jeunes donc
il avait fait ça auparavant avec mike
hodges qui était une énorme star
attendue 10 et le joker qui maintenant
maintenant et border all star d'une
ironie au niveau 2 sur lot voilà sympa
c'est un coach qui développe sur le long
terme et trouve toujours un petit gars à
une petite pépite tous les 2-3 ans qui
va envoyer aux lettres freshman et cette
année c'est max christie
on va pouvoir passer sur le deuxième
site alors vous l'avez aussi là dans le
chat si vous regardez le night boxing
lamicell deuxième coupe explorers alors
je vais le faire en même temps avec vous
si donc vous allez parce que ça va
fonctionner oui incroyable
alors ouais au pis si on va faire
michigan state
non tu veux pas eh ben c'est pas grave
tant pis on va faire autrement
hop la
michigan state donc c'est à peu près la
même chose en fait ceci tu te donnes eu
à peu près les mêmes informations sauf
que comme je suis un prof de maternelle
moi j'aime bien les couleurs tu vois de
base et même bien avant dès des jolies
d'ego mais des trucs sympas partout et
du coup c'est ainsi tient à donner des
indicateurs coloré en fonction de
l'efficacité du joueur alors il me
calcule les statistiques il va très vite
plus vite que moi
ce site qu'est ce qui nous donne il nous
donne les mêmes les mêmes infos sauf
qu'il nous permet de savoir si le joueur
ces pourcentages de réussite parlera
enfin est-ce qu'ils sont au dessus de la
moyenne de la ligue ou en dessous de la
moyenne de la ligue cité dans le vert
foncé tu es bien au-dessus de la moyenne
de la ligue c'était dans le rouge foncé
était bien en dessous de la moyenne de
la ligue rien de rien de révolutionnaire
on voit que notre ami max christine
pourcentage à 3 points il est
globalement dans la moyenne en terme de
réussite il fait pas mieux c'est pas moi
bien que les autres par contre le
pourcentage à 2 points
longue distance il est plutôt bon il ya
un peu au dessus de la moyenne et près
du panier il est dans le tiers le plus
inférieur par rapport aux camarades de
l'ansea est ce que je dis toujours c'est
que faut faire attention ces stats à son
âme et rend en contexte avec le fait que
ça prenne les joueurs et staff ou les
joueurs intérieurs je pense que de façon
assez réaliste lui dire si je me plante
mais un joueur extérieur très
régulièrement des stats plus basses près
du panier qu'un big men qui va être plus
souvent plus grand plus puissant tu le
dis si je me trompe
oui après ça dépendra des pour lesquels
au 10 mai mais c'est clair quand et big
man tu roulais qu'à la fin tu es tu
finis par un à lyon pour un dingue c'est
plus et plus l'époque où tu avais lu en
plus les big men qui veut beaucoup de
post up
donc c'est logique après tu vois je
pense que quand tu as de high school et
après tu arrives dans une assiette a
aussi une petite période d'adaptation
quand tu vois dans la raquette je pense
que
c'est le niveau supérieur donc c'est
plus physique est paraît il faut un
petit temps d'adaptation surtout que tu
voyais avant m 86 kg s'est pas c'est pas
énorme c'est un peu mon poids quoi donc
je peux et je sais de quoi je parle de
tout et fit c'est pas pareil
voilà à quoi
nous on est souvent quand on voit des
joueurs qui sont un peu en difficulté
près du panier à ce niveau là où je
perds encore contre des adductions
toujours pas encore remontés rodez des
sommes développés comme tu pourrais
avoir des jeunes tu as deux dans ton
championnat toits bleus là ont l'an
dernier on va avoir droit de bégard
inquiet pont qui est un athlète plus
plus plus
il joue déjà contre des pivots
développer en hommage aux regrets là on
est quand même jour des mecs qui ont
souvent moins de 23 ans et donc ne pas
réussir à prendre le dessus près du
cercle à ce niveau là et ne pas générer
beaucoup lancé prendre nous c'est
souvent tout qui nous inquiète wade a
titre perso max christie je suis assez
assez justement inquiet sur ce champ ce
secteur alors qu'ils étaient bons
fondamentaux mais il ya un manque de
gestion du contact toi est ce que c'est
vrai j'ai vu une ou deux actions avant
regardons un peu sur le shoot une ou
deux actions où c'est vrai qu'il expose
un peu au contact des choses comme ça
et alors il ya des joueurs qu'il arrive
à des spécialistes en en billets aussi
qu il y vraiment que sur leurs tirs mais
un mec qui à tête en kit attendu dans le
top 20 voire loterie
ça va devenir compliqué pour lui de ne
se vende qu'aujourd'hui tirs extérieurs
ci a pas autre chose à côté donc c'est
ce qu'on veut regarder maintenant
maintenant sur du film donc j'étais tout
envoyer avant le rôle pour expliquer aux
gens comment on va faire cette fois ci
j'ai essayé de faire un truc un peu plus
propre en tout cas pour max christian on
va lancer les playlists et alors j'ai
préparé une playlist vous voyez ici je
ressentir sur son dribble et sur sa
défense on va commencer par la playlist
du tir parce que c'est quand même ce qui
nous intéresse est majoritairement chez
ce joueur
au moment où je vais là lancé tu vas me
dire un peu ce que toi tu as vu au
global sur les différentes actions on va
laisser ça tout va laisser tourner sans
en boucle et après on regardera plus tôt
depuis par clip quand c'est pertinent au
ralenti on fera des arrêts et des
commentaires ok ça te la marque pas de
souci dans le chat vous hésitez pas
aussi insipide avez des questions sur le
tir vous avez des questions spécifiques
pour elle nicolas
on est là aussi pour ça donc faut pas
hésiter on est à votre entière
disposition
on est parti je lance à je vérifie que
la playlist et les biens minutes sinon
tout chez amazon sommes tombés dessus
et puis on veut être partie
alors les habitués industries mhi
connaissent mon pc ans ils savent très
bien que c'est pas une machine de guerre
koné plus près du windows 98 est de
l'époque qui lançait qui lançait un
petit solitaire que sur les nouvelles
les machines qu'on peut avoir justement
professionnel avec à synergy tout propre
qui fonctionne bien donc là je les dis
tu ne lances comme ça donc toi quand tu
as regardé le clip de croustilles est
quelque chose qui t'ont marqué sk des
choses qui est on plus des photos des
plus c'est quoi toi de l'image que tu
t'es fait
moi moi je trouve que voilà
techniquement ça ça va c'est quand même
c'est quand même correct l'un d'ailleurs
les deux joueurs les deux joueurs que tu
as envoyé
moi c'est juste que je trouve son shoot
assez énergivores j'apprends que c'est
il prend beaucoup d'énergie pour tu vois
il saute on saute assez haut
ça fait au niveau des bras ça fait un
truc il a des longs bras aussi
des souliers ouais tu vois la balle
elles ont elles montrent je trouve un
peu trop devant lui tu as a fait un
grand un grand mouvement et ça ça me
pousse à mettre pas mal de
mal de comment dire d'énergie sur
certains mouvements notamment sur ces jo
sur ses poules poulpe à gauche tu sens
qu'il est basse et ses solides c'est
solide au niveau des appuis mais des
fois il a dit la tendance à être un peu
quand il était petit lait tout seul là
comme ça c'est un peu différent mais mes
temps en temps il va il va tendance à
vraiment
battus sans que ces dévoile un peu tendu
on va dire quoi il fait peut-être aussi
tu vas pour ça que ça explique que son
pourcentage il est un peu un peu moins
bon on dirait vraiment qu'il est
vraiment s'impliquer c'est un peu ça
manque un peu de fluidité je trouve que
tu vois ouais je me suis je me suis fait
la même remarque alors pour l'envergure
du coup de 0,8
donc on a une envergure qui est positive
elle est pas non plus démentiel mais
effectivement là une belle longueur de
bras
doivent lancer l' ce que même au lancer
je trouve que c'est ce que j'aime bien
c'est qu'il souffle bien c'est quelque
chose pour moi qu'il est très important
que les jeunes je les ai battus turtur
relâcher un peu la pression ça fait
aussi partie de ta routine si tu
regardes bien même dans tous les sports
même un ronaldo avant de tirer un coup
franc tu as à souffler un bon coup
c'est je crois que c'est
scientifiquement prouvé que voilà ça ça
aide
mais tu vas y a des jeunes joueurs qui
des fois sur des lancers se mettent
beaucoup la pression et et ont tendance
à oublier ça
après tout même sa sur le lancer je
trouve ça un peu ils passent ils
baissent les gens mais il met la balle
en eau et après ils montrent tous alors
que tu vois c'est ça manque un peu de
fuites et comparé à tu vois ses poulains
quand il n'a pas vraiment de défenseurs
et qui peut vraiment aller vers l'avant
quand il a le temps vraiment de poser
son dribble fort je trouve c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment plus fluide
c'est plus intéressant comparé à ce
compte il à quelqu'un devant devant lui
et qui il veut vraiment essayer de viser
vraiment essayé de sauter quoi
on voit que c'est un joueur alors on va
le voir plus enfin qui a de la
difficulté lorsqu'il met du contact ils
paniquent un petit peu hyper hyper son
dribble arrive pas changé de mains il
est très uniforme et du coup lorsqu'il
va prendre un tir contesté en poule à
pierre souvent c'est plus par par
obligation que par choix je trouves tu
vas voir je vois gauche très vite en mai
sur sa main gauche mais un premier
contact sur son camp sur son épaule y va
plus reculés au contact et derrière on
va on va avoir une élévation plutôt que
plutôt que je te vois les deux derniers
les les deux derniers sur les sur les
poules up
ce qui était moins qu'à enfin ce qui est
plus le cas que sur les poules puis
marqué au début quand ils marquent sur
les poules hop tu sens vraiment que ton
dribbles il est bien fort qu'il arriva à
shooter enfin en phase montante et sur
les sur les plus de bouloc il a loupé
juste avant eh ben c'est pas grand chose
mais c'est
il a tendance à ajouter un peu en
descendant au sommet au sommet de son
shoot assauts des shooteurs descendants
et
bah tu perds tu perds tu perds beaucoup
de fluidité quoi beaucoup de fuites
étaient obligés de 2,2 mètres de la
force alors quand il arrive à apposer
son nom et vous même sur du catch and
shoot shoot et plus on monte en bas il
est il est beaucoup mieux tu vois ouais
ouais je vois il ya donc ont avalé boss
talus bienvenue à toi stop
tranquillement en train de faire du fils
de max cousty avec nicolas lang qui est
un spécialiste du tir on peut le dire
qui je voue du couvent au csp limoges et
à romain qui de dipoula pas gauche en
mal pour un droitier tu confirmes que
remanier pas que des bêtises
ça dépend ça dérange pas c'est monde et
tout le monde est différent il ya
deux ans vers un peu sur balles d'une
après
au niveau aussi de ou et place est à
vous tue place tabanou tata tendance
aider les joueurs qui ont plus tendance
à même en étant droitier avoir la balle
vers la hanche gauche ou la voir sur le
milieu on va dire
à d'autres il y en a d'autres c'est un
peu le contraire il aime bien avoir la
balle sur la hanche droite et dans ces
cas là
tu vois le poulpe à droite sur moi je
sais je suis beaucoup plus à l'est sur
sur un poulpe à droite
ah ouais c'est vraiment une habitude
aussi que tu vas prendre mécanique
quelque chose mais il agit il il avait
il a il a raison sur le fait qu'il ya
quand même il ya beaucoup droitier qui
aime bien les a bien aller à gauche
parce que ils ont ils n'ont pas
forcément eu cette habitude d'avoir la
balle vraiment à droite de tuer moi j'ai
toujours appris à shooter avec la balle
qui passe par des tas hanche droite qui
reste sur le côté droit justement de
prouver c'est de ne pas la mettre devant
les yeux pourquoi que sa jane mais on a
beaucoup qui ont la balle un peu au
milieu ou un peu sur la gauche et du
coup dans ce cas là c'est dit il aime
bien il aime bien poulpe à gauche on va
dire ok ok ceci ouais j'avoue que c'est
des choses que tu vas nous qu'on regarde
comment regarder du clip on essaie de
voir à peu près les habitudes je veux
regarder comme se disait la vitesse
d'exécution la fluidité la régularité au
niveau des gestes aussi
baldwin enfin ben oui non oui si on va
le voir après je trouvais des fois il y
avait des pieds qui partaient un petit
peu notamment jour des poules hop tu
arrives et des petits écarts qui qui se
faisait en bas et puis je regarde aussi
souvent est ce que le joueur il prend un
cirque comme on le disait par par choix
ou par obligation
il ya des mecs tu le vois très bien même
vous 4 en fac d'actu les oriente sur
leurs mains gauches pression droitier
bon ils vont prendre le tir parce qu'ils
ont pas ils n'ont pas la capacité avec
ses dribbles là d'aller se faire un
accès au niveau du panier ou de changer
de vitesse sur cédric changer de
direction comme il pouvait avoir sur
leurs mains fortes
equity pour l'instant il est encore un
petit peu là dessus même si on a
quelques départs à main gauche assez
intéressant je te propose
on va prendre des clips et je vais les
mettre au ralenti et s'il ya des choses
qui te marque tu veux que je pose je
fais pose aux frais et puis on en passe
quelques heures et si jamais c'est
régulier on pas sur dur la séquence
suivante que ça va
donc là du coup vous avez alors ce match
là vous avez un match contre oakland qui
est une équipe de mise mais de jeu assez
assez moyenne avec un joueur très très
fort diamal kane qui est le numéro 1 sur
le terrain mais c'est une équipe il suit
7 avait clairement un avantage un
avantage sur le papier et ils ont ils
ont pris ce match à la fin donc on est
parti au ralenti alors question l'a pas
dit je souhaite quand tu fais du
scouting c'est mieux de préciser c'est
le numéro 5 sur le terrain voilà ça peut
ça peut toujours être utile il est en
bas à droit dans le corner donc là au
niveau des murs des clips en catch and
shoot uniquement vous en avez cinq clips
d'affilée dont le dernier qui est sûr à
un échec et on pourra peut-être comparer
ce soir c'est un petit écart entre celui
où il réussit celui où il rate
donc là comme tu le disais effectivement
ils montrent assez haut moi je trouve
que ça part vite et les mâles sont
prêtes avant tu vois j'aime bien chez un
assureur voir si ces mâles sont déjà
prêtes à récupérer le ballon c'est
quelque chose que j'ai besoin j'ai
christie j'ai trouvé qu'il avait un il
avait un un bon riz un bon rythme la
sueur
et surtout ce qu'il est mais je trouve
il pas dit passe bien sous la balle
passe bien sous la balle et il shootait
ce que je disais il shoote bien
longtemps se trouve c est assez flagrant
selon plus flagrant à l'oeil nu ou ou
quand il marque a tendance à se dire
qu'il prend pas trop d'énergie et tous
ceux qui loupe c'est un peu un peu
limite trop gay n'est trop doigt comme
si vous voulez un peu trop visées du
coup ils perdent un peu trop de temps
l'air quoi
lee en fait je pense qu'il réfléchit
trop quand il rate justement
pas ça c'est
dit en plus qu'il fait une saison au
niveau des pourcentages où il n'a pas
l'habitude d'être aussi bas c'est sûr
qu'après chaque shoot
tu te poses un peu des questions quoi tu
vois là son niveau d appuis je trouve
dit prêt il prépare bien avec ça en plus
c'est une bonne passe tu vois la passe
quand elles arrivent bien ils
feraient pas bien au niveau des appuis
c'est pas mal du coup sûr se change
dernier clip qu'on a là donc on est face
à des basques avec une étude de leur
conférence sur un match qui est assez
disputée en plus on vous le rappelle il
jouer avec un gros temps durs il est
titulaire 30 minutes par amadou qui joue
trois quarts des matchs avec des grosses
responsabilités quand même hélas genre
se tire ici alors je vais mettre en
déroute 5 on a un petit écart à nicolas
et moi donc c'est possible dès fois que
koné voilà un petit décalage sur celui
aval raté donc qui vient poser un écran
le jeu reprend pas l'écran il se
repositionne directement à trois points
il le prend est ce que tu vois il le
rate ce que tu vois un décalage du coup
ici sur cette voie là j'ai l'âme aussi
figé latta me plaît
pas
trop qui m'a un peu de temps au moment
où il attrape la balle et comme s'il
veut vraiment baisser vraiment mettre
des jambes tu vois mais en même temps il
vient de faire une course où il recule
un peu c'est pas pareil qu'il arrive
vraiment de donc au final il la reçoit
quand même de face mais je trouve qu'il
était mieux quand la balle arrive un peu
de côté il n'a pas vraiment besoin de
bouger ou alors là tu vois ça un peu des
parts en recul en quoi c'est pas
toujours c'est pas toujours un shoot
ultra simple même si tu es seul au final
de devoir reculer recul reculer et quand
tu reçois la balle remets ton corps vers
l'avant quoi et donc c'est pour ça que
je pense qu'il essaie de bêtes beaucoup
de jambes et
après il n'a pas fait un gros écart
c'est limite une gamelle le truc même
reculons c'est pas des fois c'est un peu
dur pour moi qui le dit je ne pense pas
qu'il pompe trop vers le bas qui trône
là dessus c'est effectivement une
question il a été question qu'il a posée
ouais ouais mais c'est une question qui
est posée ouais ouais
là je trouve que
trouver je trouvais que sur les shoots
d'avant qui mettait ben tu vois la balle
elle arrive bien il mais il me passe
bien sous la balle mais son sens sans
trop en faire
là c'est vrai qu'il a où il va il va il
va chercher vachement bas est derrière
pour remonter il a l'air d'avoir des
cannes mais ça reste quand même
compliqué quoi et on a stoppé à kovy tx
donc un hameau du tir qui demande dans
le lot est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une bonne
mécanique de tir donc je te laisse je te
laisserais pendant celle là pour toi
c'est quoi une bonne mécanique de tir
ben déjà déjà il ya je pense qu'il ya
différents critères et
ça dépend aussi de thach thât
physionomie ta morphologie comment moi
j'écoutais déjà djédjé reddick a des
nerfs fois qu'ils disaient que des fois
quand tu avais des bras trop long des
mains trop grande c'était très compliqué
de devenir un bon shooteur même avec
beaucoup de travail quand tu vois c'est
quelque chose qui m'a pas mal fait
réfléchir parce qu'on a tous des fois de
tendance à éduquer un peu les jeunes en
leur donnant tu as tous les mêmes
conseils alors qu'ils sont tous
différents mais pour moi déjà c'est ça
va sur voilà des bases et déjà quand tu
lâches
l'achetons
balle à la fin même si tout le chemin de
tout le trajet avant ça n'a pas été
parfait on va dire tant que ton coup de
je pense qu'il est il est quand même
aligné vers le cirque c'est déjà très
important on voit la balle bien en main
donc avoir les doigts les doigts bien
écarté sans la balle
pense qu'il vaut mieux avoir les doigts
bien écartées et toucher un peu être la
paume même si je suis pas fan que que
voilà n'est pas vraiment pas vouloir
toucher avec la peau mais avant les
mains et les doigts tout serré où tu vas
bien la balle en main commise et
dernière chose pour moi c'est passé sous
la barre
et
c'est comme on disait avant voilà là on
a vu qu'il a cherché trop bas mais
vraiment ce petit mouvement de
demain c'est dur sans vidéo mais mais
chercher avec la balle reste passer son
coup de passer son coude sous le ballon
en fait nan mais c'est dur sans vidéo de
deux mois des pommes finement après ce
que je fais le geste chez moi
tu vois deux donc passé avec la balle
sous le comme un mouvement appelé
d'épaulé jeter tu vois je sais pas si tu
vois ce que c'est ouais proposé tu veux
pour le soft si tu veux faire kiffer tu
te fais un petit fasse comme si nous
enregistrons une
prochaine fois que tu me la joues et
j'en ai besoin de fonds pour cette forme
et très ça sur le compte twitter
d'envergure tu vois petit cours des
cours de gauting
pas de souci mais déjà des jaloux est
passé sous la balle pour moi c'est très
très important est très important et
après sur la fin du geste la finition
bassa de limites en découle est souvent
on dit aux jeunes le poignet le poignet
le poignet ils ont tendance à attendre
le braille à faire le premier à la fin
parce qu'on leur a dit au final le pony
sais c'est que la dernière c'est que la
dernière étape ques et c'est comme en
fait c'est moi je travaille avec des
enfants du coût de 2 3 à 5 ans donc les
petits et très souvent alors on leur dit
et on prend la tête aux parents avec we
l'écriture il tient pas là son crayon de
chappatte version foot mais en fait on
se rend très vite compte c'est des
gamins là que s'ils n'ont pas développé
d'abord la grande motricité et donc ça
peut pas développer les pôles le bras
l'avant-bras et cetera ils pourront
jamais être propre niveau de leurs mains
s'il n'a pas développé le une grande ton
corps en fait tu pourras jamais être
précis sur la finition sur le jour le
bout quoi c'est comme faire monter un
meuble si tu commences par l'étape 18 ou
faut faire serrer les 10 méga vente a
fait n'importe quoi tu as mis les
planches dans leurs attaques ces terres
là ça n'a absolument aucun sens en fait
après tu vois des premiers aux bases
mois sur les sur legend bâche un peu
plus chez un peu plus
relax on va dire ça veut dire que
souvent quand les plus jeunes on
t'explique faut avoir les pieds vers le
panier des choses comme ça et et au
final il vaut mieux être à l'aise je
pense au niveau des jambes e on est tous
pareils on est tous différent donc peut
être très tendu quand une baisse parce
que tu veux à tout prix avoir les les
pieds les pieds vers le cercle et après
sur le fait de passer sous la balle je
pense que ce sera plus facile de le voir
sur les lancers francs élu par exemple
le fait de passer là bas je trouve qu'il
le fait plutôt bien sûr les sur les
shoots en rite qui met mais aux
lancers-francs le fait de mettre cette
balle sous son menton et de fléchir
avant bas il perd un peu ça qu'on a
aussi osé lancer franc on est là on est
là quand même pour répondre d'abord aux
deux principales donc on a choisi pour
les précédents avant donc la aux lancers
francs alors toujours le niveau des
équipes qu'on a c'est sur quelque chose
qui est toujours des composés une mer de
face et on à la fin de l'action sur le
côté tu me dis quand tu es devant et je
les mettre en replay du coup
stop alors à toi j'étais là quand il a
la balle devant quand il a la balle
devant la tête là alors ouais j'attends
envie de fait germer celui-là
là vous partie multi est un peu bas
encore
stop
ouais tu vois balla bon tu vois pas ces
gens et là en gros il est déjà fléchi
donc là il a la balle il a la balle de
voeux devant le menton et il fait un
temps d'arrêt tu vois sans que tout le
fait de passer sous la balle donnée un
peu de rythme est bon au final il a
perdu et comme si tu doit soulever
quelque chose je fais pas tu as quelque
chose d'un peu lourd mata plus petit a
plus tendance a plus tendance à passer
dessous pour le soulever que de peu de
le mettre sous son menton des cendres
est arrêté puis après pour le pôle jetez
donc c'est après ça reste ça reste un
lancer-franc dogon final coûte si tu te
sens ici tu te sens bien comme ça
t'as pas de tapas de défense des lancers
francs est ce que tu es vraiment obligé
d'avoir le shoot parfait
il vaut mieux il vaut mieux être à
l'aise que changer pour un lancer-franc
ci après sur le shoot à trois points que
le rythme il le fait il le fait
naturellement ça va quoi
rager frisé sur la position moins
durement dû relâcher on a un peu les
pieds décollés aux nappes d'eau un peu
cas brestoise atteint 700 bloqués ou pas
sur la fin du shoot là comme ça a
commencé en l'air
c'est trop tard de l'air ouais l'avait
alors j'essaie de frizot d'ailleurs non
mais alors est ce que j'ai une meilleure
équité sur le deuxième serait sûr après
sur le lancer franc au tout début juin
apprend que la balle elle est quand même
bien sûr la paume du ha
mais des fois c'est un peu je sais que
tu vois de plus en plus d'image des
joueurs nba qui ont la balle sur la
paume et même moi je me suis rendu
compte d'avoir une ou deux photos de moi
où tu as l'impression qu'elle est sur la
paume oui des fois je me demande si
c'est pas un peu pas un peu la photo qui
fait ça ou la caméra tu vois là en fait
là tu peux pas très bien voir ça se
trouve ya trouvé un espace
entre les doigts et la main fin donc
c'est dur à dire quoi on a du pont
pixels bien sympa en plus à moitié fait
savoir mardi soir en soie en soit tu vas
son shoot au shoot il est solide et
solidaire n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de
souci mais c'est vrai que il ya je pense
qu'il peut s'améliorer sur les sur le
fait de pas aller chercher trop bas
comme dirait qui comme disait romain
avant en corse a déçu c'est que sur
certains shoot après aux lancers-francs
j'ai dit ça pour parce que c'est quelque
chose qui m'a un peu choqué mais encore
une fois un temps que temps que ton
pourcentage aux lancers francs il est il
est correct ça va rien de d'aller gagner
au niveau technique pour que tu perdes
au niveau mental quoi ouais ouais c'est
vrai que maintenant de plus en plus on
nous dit qu'en fait tant que ça donc ce
efficace est le genre il y à l'aise avec
finalement c'est devenu ça la priorité
on a une demande importance du regard
sous la balle sur la remontée mon avis
qu'est ce qui veut dire pas du regard
sur la balle alors au mas est à toi
qu'est-ce que tu dors pas le regard sous
la balle soit soit précis s'il te plaît
sur mail offensif en attendant tête où
on a un peu plus d'action entièrement
sur le lotissement safran kg et la
tumeur à l'outil
on a le geste vase et en face
il dit sur l'armée
alors je pense qu'il parle pas de
l'armée de terre ou de l'armée de terre
ouais bah moi je te jure je sais pas
trop pourquoi il met cette balle devant
fin tu vises un tu vises le cercle et tu
sais pas et atabal tata balle devant toi
basse et ça fait un peu bizarre moi je
comprends je comprends pas trop pourquoi
parce que tu as toujours toute la
routine ça tu as salé un salaire
solidifie culte bien le il devrait
encore y en as tu vois moi je sais que
j'aime pas forcément regarder le cercle
pendant
5 secondes d'ailleurs chez sur les
lancers francs je préfère notamment sur
les
turler sur les gars qui savent qu'ils
savent quand même mais ajouté j'aime
bien les routines plus courte mais pas
maintenant a réfléchi à écoute tu fais
ton g7 en voit
que les trucs un peu long mais là ça
m'interroge quand même pas mal de savoir
pourquoi il après coup de parler trop
vite fait état depuis 10 15 ans
de l'âge du film s'il a fait de la
compétition jeunes ou pas et je vous
retrouverai du clip au niveau inférieur
et je te jeter notifié richard twitter
pour voir si une régularité on pourra on
pourra reparler à l'occasion
alors on va peut-être passer a
maintenant plus le dribble et c'est
juste j'aimerais bien qu'on revienne sur
une chose
ça va être dans le dans le tiers prix of
the rebels vraiment quand il est
important de balle et qu' il prend un
tir à trois points de la ligne
extérieure notamment un clip où il va le
faire
avec après un side step steinbach non
plus je te montre ça je le retrouve ici
on va revenir depuis le début ce sera
plus facile pour moi hop là
que tu me dises que temps pour peu qu'on
a eu beaucoup de catch and shoot ce qui
vous est majoritairement j'aimerais
avant tout d'aller sur une projection
peut-être futur sur sa capacité à
pouvoir prendre un tir à trois points
derrière un écran
après quelques dribbles
je pense que c'est celui là on va
vérifier ça tout de suite
hop là il reste que c'est celui-là ou
pas
alors c'est le projet gelé au ralenti on
est face à du yukon nous dans une
défaite
face à yukon en une du temps brand mi
temps face à houston qui est une équipe
assez sérieuse avec pas mal de joueurs
assez athlétique donc là sur ce système
là
bon après c'est ricky pays fin il fait
un gros écarts mais c'est pas un shoot
facile notamment à 60 et bac 4 et bac à
droite pour un droitier et c'est pas
c'est pas super simple à faire
et je ne sais pas si tu vois là il a
plutôt bien bien lu la défense
et je sais pas s'il a vraiment
l'habitude de faire fabriquer voit il le
fait que le gars y reviennent derrière
le jeune maman quoi ah oui d'ailleurs
plus le donc de le 44 qui est latin jour
très très athlétique qui a mis de
beaucoup de blocs pendant pendant le
match qui avait déjà une pression dans
la première mi-temps
pour le niveau du volume on avait je
n'avais vu 1 95% du catch quelque chose
qui fait très très peu c'est la seule
action vous faites tout je les ai vus
prendre
vraiment un un poulpe après un dribble
peinture un tir après un gros écart
comme ça et je trouve ça toujours
intéressant pour de la projection est ce
qu'il pourrait le faire ou pas donc
voilà j'ai voulu faire ce clip là est ce
que tu penses que tu trouve qu'après les
cars qui fait il reste
nous aiguiller par rapport aux autres
tiers qui prend ou est ce qu'il ya
où il est ce qu'il ya un vrai changement
date tata l'impression que ouais enfin
dans le sens où à la fin tu sens qu'il
n'a pas vraiment pu finir son geste
comme il voulait
généralement il reste il reste vraiment
beaucoup après ces gestes le geste
serait là mais là tu sens vraiment que
le mec il ay là il a beaucoup gêné quoi
il faut que vous les shoots d'avant il
n'a pas la ville a pas l'habitude d'être
d'avoir autant de
de concertation sur un shoot de cidre ou
quoi ouais ça c'est quelque chose que je
n'ai pas dis pas tu vois il est toujours
sa main droite mais même avant il a
souhaité autre shoot il avait laissé un
peu les deux mains là tu sens que tu
sens qu'il ya un truc qui l'a gêné ouais
c'était quelque chose qu'on connaissait
de souvent souvent aussi estimé tu vois
que sa capacité à tirer sous la pression
c'est vrai que c'est un joueur qu'on le
disait quand tu lis mais du contact
quand tu vas lui mettre une main dans le
visage quand tu vas lui chargé dessus il
va il va toujours avoir un temps de
réflexion peu plus
plus d'hésitation et seulement ça finit
par une para para tirs ratés quoi donc
là il a eu du mal à gérer les belles
contestation et au niveau supérieur ils
vont en avoir des athlètes surtout que
même si on a beaucoup de situations où
on va avoir un démarquage h soit après
un écran avec un big et du coup le son
défenseur d'agde est repris dans l'écran
en nba va avoir du switch est donc très
rapidement il vas y vas avoir des tirs
bien plus compliquée à prendre
position
est ce que tu voulais voir de tout sur
le tir ou est ce que ça te va si on
passe maintenant un petit peu ah non ce
qui s'est fait en d'autres
mots on va diminuer donc on avait car
dans le ciel qui nous dit sa position
des mains sur le ballon c'est à montrer
dans toutes les écoles de basket un
cycle falls où j'essaie de dire
correctement et de l'action de la main
nue friteuse ou à l'huile et il est
tombé à ces amoureux de ces amoureux du
tir et on sait que pierre pierrât
accordent de l'importance là dessus
ils m'ont d'ailleurs est ce qu'il ya eu
des vents chauds de choix de la région
cette action il a l'air en simultané
c'est plus dur après le dribble à mon
humble avis ils my opinion t'en penses
quoi
pas de pointe a pas de juste vérité tu
as tu es là il aurait pu sur l'action
avant que tu as montré il aurait pu très
bien faire faire droite gauche ou même
et c'est un peu flotté la balle pour
enchaîner sur la gauche droite
c'est vrai qu'après sur acier simultané
pour remonter
c'est pas super simple mais il a quand
même d'avoir des cannes donc je pense
qu'il a les qualités pour le faire
alors on maquille préférence motrices
lagacé selon le joueur ouais et puis
après si on a alors on va le voir là je
montrais laisser tourner on va voir que
c'est un joueur qui est plus à l'aise
sur sa main droite et du départ main
gauche mais complet sur la main droite
est
systématiquement lorsqu'il part en
dribble et qui changent pas de change
pas de direction c'est pas un joueur qui
va vraiment changer de mains une fois
qu'il est parti au niveau du panier donc
assez facile à lire et comme il est
encore assez fin et qui domine pas chaud
au niveau du contact sur le physique
défensivement ça peut être plus
compliqué face à pas défensivement c'est
facile de s'adapter pour lui face à lui
non voilà j'ai mis plusieurs plus en
action on va le voir partir ma droite me
voir partir ma gauche on peut voir ses
qualités athlétiques sur les premiers
clips où ils montrent assez haut sadate
est plutôt intéressant
toi qu'est ce que t'en as pensé de
de notre ami max quiz timbaland et
athlétiquement parlant
ben écoute heureusement moi j'avais
quand même plus que jamais le shoot
que tout ça donc j'ai pas envie de juger
un gars que j'ai pas assez vu tout
j'essaie de regarder pas mal mais là de
ce que je vois sur les
sur les images mais je n'y échappe un
peu en live la
folie sur les sur toile à lacets qu'on
dise avant que comment il explose au
contact ouais
quand il la côte il a du rythme j'ai un
succès voilà dès qu'il a du ried ça va
ça va un peu mais dès que tu avec des
cumuls pousse un peu et qui perd ce
rythme là bas il a il a plus de mal à
finir quoi
ouais c'est ça je te jure je te rejoins
totalement en fait voilà on vient depuis
le début - chaumont gens ma vidéo arrivé
sur le sur le premier dunk au niveau
d'élévation en transition c'était juste
pour montrer ses qualités athlétiques
ici hop je le remets ça ralentit
rapidement on connaît aujourd'hui
1.20 hop hu est arrivé dessus ici c'est
bon
la belle athlète au début quand je la
regarde après une fois je me dirais sa
trajectoire qui va traiter de plus de
sol etc amelia des capacités athlétiques
on échouera deuxièmement une deuxième
action ici vous avez un finir avec après
un push back je crois ouais c'est ça
ouais non jour du jour devant un trailer
en punk aux signaux qui montrent assez
haut quand il n'y a pas de contestation
ici on le voit tu vois alors d'un petit
décalage par rapport à moi
sur ce clip là tu vois que le de la
défense elle lui oppose directement un
premier corps est tout de suite faire la
passe parce que je vais pas trop
capacité à aller m'engouffrer dans cette
défense de des princes qu'avec les deux
défenseurs là le a et le ca qui ferme
l'accès au panier
je vais me retrouver en difficulté donc
tout de suite fait dans la transmission
on voit ici après l'écran g ouais je le
redis jackson sur les images que tu
demandes de plus avant que c'est un gars
qui est à l'air
qui a l'air un peu intelligent tu vois
la cantine qui après pour moi c'est le 2
qui est qui et qui bouge pas bien non
plus mais
tu vois elles sont dans son cas il vient
il vient et dégâts et bouge pas du tout
donc le space est à la base il est pas
il n'y a pas trop non plus je pense non
non non
wade joue avec un alors il joue pas avec
un vrai mais dans cette année c'est de
bricoler donc là c'est tyson walcott qui
est là effectivement c'est important
quand tu es un jeune d'avoir un vrai
maintenant pour mettre le ballon au bon
endroit surtout pour un shooter comme ça
et le côté messieurs gadget c'est leur
groupe en fait cette saison le garde
play
sur ce clip lala ici donc on va être sur
un drive là on change de direction ça
qui m'intéressait et on va aller et
c'est terminé mais on y difficulté à la
finition près de près du cercle sur un
gros corps
dommage que dans les faits il avait fait
un bon bout ouais je sais nager en moins
mais c'est dommage qu'il a pas réussi à
finir
à ideye alors oui c'est un peu plus et à
la fin j'ai et puis j'ai vu très peu de
finition ma gauche tu vois sur un joueur
on va attendre souvent au niveau
supérieur très très haut pour un vrai
havre attaquons au niveau du cercle on
aimerait bien avoir une définition au
niveau de la main gauche pour pouvoir
avoir les yeux plat qui serais plus
protégée par rapport aux big adverse et
ils repassent sur sa main droite alors
qu'il avait réussi à faire le changement
de direction
tels contacts et du coup il n'y a pas
une termine pacifiquement
donc la suivante tu vas l'avoir on est
sur un drève main droite en sortie
d'écran donc là il va aller finir sur
adama sanogo le pivot de yukon qui est
un pivot assez physique même déjà bien
physique bien développé de 2 m 0,8 là
j'aime bien le fait qu'il lie au contact
alors il ya un décalage qui est fait on
le disait après l'écran alors on revient
dessus
je pense qu'il a il allait mieux à finir
au contact parce que tu as il arrive à
prendre beaucoup plus de vitesse c'est
ça la danse à lille et paris les pas
vraiment contesté il arrive à
villareal va bien s'engager
après tu vois il a quand même les cannes
pour y aller quoi
il est à 7 l'éthique la c est
relativement basse à mobiliser dans
l'axé nord-sud en laque ce panier panier
même latéralement il est intéressant
comme on disait au niveau supérieur ce
jour d'action la très très probablement
y aurait eu un switch entre le 24 et le
11 et du coup là il serait peut-être
plus en difficulté parce que son
défenseur aurait pas autant de retard
donc là on est le 11 à coque est en fait
un pivot qui est décalé par nécessité
par un manque de moyens humains sera je
reposte de quatre là où le 24 nano
keynes est un joueur qui devrait finir
ap après on a une bille et mais sur
quelque chose de très uniforme sur un
mouvement de fuite très très uniforme il
a les capacités pour pouvoir aller au
panier
sur cette action ce que j'aime bien
c'est la capacité avec ses fondamentaux
s'est appuyée à se créer un décalage
pour pouvoir justement prendre un pilote
derrière on avait vu dans les stades qui
prenait plus de poulpe à mi distance
qu'à trois points et qu'il avait
l'efficacité assez intéressante
et encore une fois comme tu le disais un
jour qui s'élève à ces eaux dans la
partie basse ils montent très haut
là je suis là pour moi il est vraiment
ils étaient prêts non pas
à tuer c'était très robin comme un robot
quoi tu restes allemand il tua il a dit
hey lamia il a mis beaucoup de jus sur
son sur son job ce qui est plutôt bien
parce qu'il a réussi à trouver
la séparation mais après comme 10e
romain avant il allait chercher très bas
sur les cannes il a sauté très haut et
même son bras à la fin donc je sais
qu'il faut bien le vsab il faut bien
avoir la main vers le haut mais là il a
la main vraiment au dessus enfin tu as
limite trop dessus de lui quoi
là c'est trop forcé ou mal dites c'est
compliqué énergivores ça rejoint ce que
toi tu disais ouais exactement
donc là on est encore un peu plus sur le
même au début la même fan de tiers sauf
que cette fois ci va se créer son accès
aux paniers sur champ de la main gauche
et l'aiment bien celui-là le diable à
jeune afrique il le maîtrise quand même
plutôt bien
quelque chose qui faisait beaucoup déjà
au niveau inférieur
et encore une par jour de la sortie sur
de la sortie d'écran cette fois ci on
est sur un petit flotteur main droite
donc ça jour qui est quand même pas mal
de touché et ce move lui permet
aujourd'hui de remettre ce move lui
permettre d'aller enfin donc temps
d'éviter d'aller au niveau du panier au
niveau du contact alors c'est un mec
intelligent souvent reproche aux jeunes
de te re utiliser le flotteur au niveau
n 6 est pour nous c'est un peu être un
indicateur assez négatif mais au niveau
supérieur vu que pour l'instant il n'y a
pas l'épaisseur et la capacité à finir
au contact ça devrait devrait être une
énorme son arsenal
germaine dernière fois
chez des jeunes est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui va te déranger ou pas que très
rapidement un jeu ne l'utilisent le
flotteur leur honneur plutôt que d'aller
au panier ou à tancer par un problème si
un jour je jouerai force
non mois après je penche pour objectif
j'ai fait des flotteurs toute ma vie
donc pas forcément objectif mais je veux
dire ça il faut il faut voilà je pense
qu'il faut très vite côté jeunes
avoir une idée de ce que tu vas devenir
physiquement si tu cites a pas les
qualités pour aller finir sur un grand
ça sert à rien de parler travailler avec
un assistant coach qui va être poussé à
finir au cercle alors que en match
le match aura jamais les qualités pour
le faire donc dans ce cas là tu nettoies
très vite sur sur sur un flotteur ou sur
et quand arrive vers le cercle ou vdd
défunte des choses comme ça par contre
si la hausse est problématique c'est
quand tu as un gars qui
met la tête au cercle et qui est très
physique et qui qui osent pas qu'ils
osent pas aller au contact et qui qui
cherchent des flotteurs alors qu'il a il
n'a pas le toucher pourquoi tu vois donc
ça dépend ça dépend de qui tu es et kiki
tu peux devenir
c'est toujours ce qu'on disait une
franchise nba draft des fois découvert
une faille à défaut si c'est une
béquille drafté mal dégâts parce
qu'elles ne doivent que pour des choses
ne soient ils vont pas faire au niveau
supérieur parce qu'il fait finalement
c'est une qualité qui sont au niveau n 6
et mais qui peu rapace 30 clair parce
que déficit athlétique parce que style
de jeu et c'est
soit des fois elles vont aller les
chercher sur des choses sur lesquelles
ils sont pas à l'aise on décale
totalement des joueurs vont faire ce
qu'ils sont pas et c'est peut-être une
des plus grosses erreurs possibles et ça
veut détruire des carrières quoi
sur ce clip là et après on finira choix
je crois cette partie là de son jeu et
on passera rapidement sur sa défense
c'est cette difficulté à aller au
contact n'a vu c'est un mec qui était
plutôt capable de monter verticalement
mais lorsqu'il va arriver sur du contact
justement il va est pas totalement
explosé et très souvent trop souvent on
retrouve ce genre de ce genre d'action
sur deux finitions raté ce qui explique
ce plan est très très faible là qu'on
voit une belle rotation défensive et
j'explose totalement contact et j'arrive
pas il ya trouvé la faute ni à dia finir
sur nos défenseurs direct
[Musique]
voilà
si vous avez des questions dans le chatt
assure max christie vous n'hésitez pas
on va tenir la défense après on passera
à patrick baldwin junior est un petit
tweet entre les deux on enchaînera
tranquillement de toute façon ce qu'on
voyait en attaque au niveau de l'ue des
qualités athlétiques du jour on va la
retrouver on va la retrouver en défense
c'est à dire que c'est un joueur qui
bouge bien qui peut monter haut qui se
déplace bien latéralement qui oriente
correctement son porteur de balle parce
qu'il a des longs bras et parce qu'il a
une belle mobilité c'est un joueur
intelligent mais qui va qui va souvent
souffrir sur assouan attaquant qui est
plus physique que lui soit sûr de la
rotation après un cloud vraiment on le
voit très souvent en difficulté quand il
faut amener l'aide près du panier et et
revenir sur un os défendra tire là il
est souvent battue
donc on va faire tourner sa up si j'aime
bien sa façon de contester les tirs
alors à presse pour le tir sur la tête
mais il y reste en phase
iib si défensivement tu voyais tient
bien latéralement concédé porteur de
balle
qui sont pas capables de créer un
décalage de changer de direction est ce
que tout ce que j'aime ce genre de clip
c'est qu'ils changent de mains beaucoup
testé le tir quelque chose qui ont dit
très souvent pour les intérieurs
être capable du coup de d'utiliser de
changer de mains utiliser ma droite -
gauche pour contester à tirer très
souvent il ya des mecs qui disent que
leur main forte
ouais après après défense j'ai pas trop
de parler
c'est pas ta spécialité fait pas un mot
de mon
nom à épiler j'aime pas de quoi les mecs
qui n'arrive pas à le faire et qu'ils te
disent quoi faire donc j'ai je vais
m'abstenir à obama si clark va donc là
même le mode rush comprends moi j'arrive
pas à le faire on est vraiment chaud de
la pureté ouais mais bon
t'as jamais vu ne pas le faire donc
c'est vous on doit y avoir il doit y
avoir des vidéos qui existent mais elles
ne sortiront jamais sur les internets
ils prétextent aurait toujours un
problème deux
nouveaux
donc là pour vrai pour boucler sur le
problème défensif
non bon on est revenue sur le 1er mai
jour la taxe est donc voilà globalement
je pense que ça peut être en nba un
défenseur intelligent ça va être un mec
qui sera toujours bien placé dans les
rotations avoir du coup c'est peut-être
cette difficulté sur survenir et des et
reprendre son joueur et puis va falloir
prendre de la masse on sait que c'est en
nba savent très bien faire de façon plus
ou moins d'un moins dire conventionnel
on dira mais voilà c'est un joueur qui
va devoir prendre de la masse pour
pouvoir encaisser les contacts que ce
soit en attaque et surtout en défense
pour pour être sur le parquet toi si tu
devais faire une une projection à terme
qu'est ce que tu le vois devenir qu'est
ce que tu le verrait bien devenir dans
quel contexte aimerait plutôt le voir
évoluer et qu'est ce que tu penses qu'il
te qu'ils devraient travailler
ben
tu vois je sais que physiquement c'est
quand même assez léger je trouve que je
trouve qu'ils allaient installer un jour
assez intelligent
tu as quatre termes c'est un joueur qui
va
c'est pas dans les mauves draft combine
vous le mettez ou des choses comme ça
ils vont la paix
on est chauds de la fin du premier tour
début second tour
ouais tu vois c'est pas c'est pas un
gars où je me dis c'est sûr et certain
qu'il va faire une une grosse carrière
en nba tu va déprendre je pense que ça
dépend des prochaines années qui veut
s'y veux exister je pense qu'avec son
physique c'est que la manette qui va
devoir améliorer les des pourcentages
pour la pour
pouvoir écarter le jeu s'il joue avec
une
tu as une star qui va le trouver sur des
choux des choses comme ça
après dans ça se voit que c'est un jeu
intelligent tu vois qu'ils qui justement
alors est ce que c'est parce qu'il n'a
pas les capacités ou parce qu'il a parce
qu'il est intelligent ça c'est dur à
dire mais tu vois quand ils voient
inédit lâche la balle
des choses comme ça et après je constate
aura toujours la place pour tu vois pour
des joueurs intelligents que ce soit
soit en nba à côté d'une star ou alors
peut-être
y pose c'est un profil qui je trouve
qu'il pour l'europe et aussi c'est pas
déconner non plus quoi
toi s'il arrive de mots csp limoges ça
te va
d'ailleurs nous avions la soirée non
plus mais derrière toi bien sûr toujours
en rotation tu vois si je n'avais
j'écoute je le souhaite je lui souhaite
là il est encore halloween bijoux c'est
un peu mieux pour l'instant corps
n'était valorise pas ton championnat
non mais oui on pense aussi que c'est un
gars qui sera toujours utile dans une
équipe
je pense que là actuellement il ya
personne qui se dit ça je vais le
prendre et je vais le développer comme
porteur de balle ce qui pouvait être une
crainte en début de saison parce qu'il
montrait au lycée qu'il avait le bâlois
ils avaient la balle en main donc à la
marche parce qu'il a réglé cette
question là on va le pas lui demander de
jouer des pick and roll genre de choses
là
et que de toute façon tu tues le fou
dans un corner tu fous dans du mouvement
et apportera toujours une valeur
positive
de ce côté là donc voilà comment on va
passer au deuxième joueur alors le
deuxième joueur c'était un jour pour le
coup qui était très très très très très
cotés il s'appelle patrick baldwin
junior on a eu la chance de pouvoir le
voir alors se passa de sully si
normalement savarese ait affiché j'ai
fait rajouter un petit tweet en
attendant vite pour pour inviter les
gens à nous rejoindre si jamais patrick
baldwin d'une heure on ait la chance de
pouvoir le voir comme on le voit sur la
belle photo avec l'équipe u19 qui nous a
battus en finale dé delà du championnat
s'il avait pu voir un peu la compétition
pas du tout
la finale j'avais regardé ouais quand on
parle à montbard il avait été assez
discret
liszt commencer les matches il avait été
dans un rôle vraiment uniquement de
tireurs à trois points chauds de la fin
de chaîne c'est plus notre ami kenneth
lofteuse junior avec ses physique
atypique je sais pas si tu vois le pivot
très très volumineux qui nous avait
détruit sous le panier et ouais ouais
fait mal et diana il vit qui est
actuellement top 5 de la prochaine draft
très sûrement l'arrière explosif
laquelle est très bien transition qui
doit souffrir alors que les ailiers
ballerines junior réaliser une gramme
était plutôt discret
il arrive il a fait le choix de ne pas
rejoindre une énorme équipe une énorme
écuries mais de jouer pour les milwaukee
bucks qui sont une équipe de minimes et
dior dans la conférence horizons et
surtout de jouer pour son papa c'est un
joueur qui est très proche de sa famille
et qui a jamais voulu
jamais voulu s'éloigner donc il a fait
ce choix qui est assez osé qui inédit
surtout pour la conférence horizons ils
n'ont jamais eu de grosses recrues le
dernier mais qui sont sortis
qui a fait un niveau assez coordonnés
world à l'époque et qu'en valais où il
n'était pas attendu pour être le joueur
qu'il est maintenant donc c'est vraiment
une bombinette qui est arrivé
et pour l'instant alors moi je disais
dans un article que j'avais écrit sur
lui en début de saison ça peut être tu
me diras ce que tu en penses tu à double
tranchant parce que on s'attendait à ce
qu'ils dominent litigieuses une
conférence stéphane hallegatte une
adversité vraiment en dessous qui domine
qui soit vraiment rayonnant et caetera
et que a contrario ch'ti dominé pas dans
une conférence très faible c'était très
très très inquiétant pour la suite de sa
carrière
toi est-ce que tu voies dont on entend
les jeunes que tu peux rencontrer
d'aider des jeunes qui font le choix de
jeu temps des équipes peut-être un peu
moins un peu moins forte d'avoir un gros
temps de jeu des grosses responsabilités
et derrière de s'en mordre les doigts ou
c'est plutôt tu conseillera plutôt des
dans un cadre dans un cadre victorieux
quitte à jouer un peu moins
non honnêtement moi c'est vraiment une
question que je me suis toujours posé
enfin souvent j'essaie de questions même
que je vois le des coéquipiers aulas qui
sont passés par différents background
mais en leur demandant par exemple
pendant avec ton fils qu'est ce que tu
ferais si c'est un prospect est ce que
tu le met très souvent je prendrais
plutôt l'exemple de la france mais est
ce que tu me mettrai à l'asvel
qui voit la joue l'euroligue mais par
contre tu as 15 joueurs
ou alors
voix lorsque tu le mettrais une équipe
qui vise le maintien mais tu sais qu'il
va jouer quoi
et moi plus ça avance plus je vois les
gars plus j'veux plus je suis vraiment
partisan de du temps de jeu quoi du
temps de jeu et quand tu es jeune alors
après ans et ancien moi j'ai pas envie
de m'avancer je connais pas assez je
sais pas s'il est si les scouts vont
forcément se se dire mais il joue dans
une équipe
mauvaise conférence voilà parce que du
coup tu joues pas les mêmes adversaires
quand je te prends l'exemple de tu vois
du championnat de france ben que tu
joues dans la mer et qui pour la
dernière tu vas un peu joué les tuvache
tu vas jouer les mêmes adversaires sauf
que tu auras juste plus de temps de jeu
quoi et moi honnêtement c'est vrai que
quand tu es jeune je trouve que
aller dans une équipe où tu as ou tu vas
jouer c'est pour moi plus important que
que tout notamment quant à d voilà des
objectifs qui sont victimes de graves
c'est vraiment un objectif individuel
même si voilà ton club à gagner des
parts gagner de l'argent mais mais pour
moi le
l'objectif c'est de jouer si tu étais tu
perds écoute
s'étaient pas séparés c'est pas pour moi
c'est pas le plus important qu'on ok ok
alors oui tu disais rainsy a
effectivement les calendriers sont très
hétérogènes pour ceux qui sont sur le
chat et qui suivent pas trop hâtif de
loin des buts c'est au tour des équipes
qui sont pas dans ta conférence dont
classer les clubs les équipes entre qui
vont loin ailleurs six autres qui vont
se rencontrer qui vont se dire bon
écoute ça te dit qu'on pense qu'à une
date pour jouer ces matches-là ce jour
là et c'est assez puisque les faits les
équipes qui font leur petit lentilles
perdrions d'entre elles
milwaukee a joué deux équipes de ahmed
gens donc deux équipes de crosse
conférence colorado et flo rida ils se
sont fait défoncer vraiment défoncé
d'ailleurs même contre des équipes
faibles ils ont perdu ça qui était
inquiète tant les ont commencé la saison
avec une victoire et six défaites
donc voilà un début très très compliqué
et puis maintenant ils jouent leur match
de conférences enfin donc c'est à dire
qu'il joue vraiment les équipes de la
même préférence avant d'aller dans l'eau
dans leur tournoi pour savoir qui
gagnera temps de la conférence est qui
aura peut-être une chance d'aller au
march madness d'arrière et pour
l'instant patrick baldwin comme on le
voit dans les stats il est blessé
donc
donc vraiment le la saison un peu
cauchemardesque pour ce pour ce jeune la
romagne lundi 2 mai 08 3 6 kg s'est
monté fin effectivement il est encore
pas très développé même si je pense que
depuis moment où on a rentré les les
informations sur le site il a un peu
pris de masse par contre en terme de
deux tie hélas pas il n'a pas évolué
notre me patrick baldwin junior et puis
l'été dernier et pierre qui s'est pris
un avertissement du du bot excusez-moi
pierre gillet le bot là
il est bas comme toi tu voyais qui a
fermé du goulag le boss un saint homme
un bond du goulag un geste parce que tu
as dû lui fatale du maître 5 et moggi et
ses limites ces quatre donc le propane
ait pas moi qui te moder pour aller sur
les stats brut
alors on disait que c'était un gars qui
était très réputé pour son tir haut
niveau au niveau inférieur l'équipe
américaine il a il prenait quasiment que
des tirs à trois points là cette année
on voit ses six tirs a trop porté par un
match pour une réussite qui est assez
faible 32% au niveau des lancers francs
3 5 par match il ya 114 % de réussite ce
qui est correct sûrs d'être au niveau
d'excellence de la part de patrick
baldwin
il joue 28 minutes par match donc son
père a décidé de pas le surcharger moi
je pensais qu'il allait vraiment joué 33
34 35 minutes papa il a dit il a dit que
non ils voulaient le faire le considère
comme un joueur classique que ce soit
une superstar ou pas que soient mes
clients en biais ou non
il n'ya pas d'avoir des problèmes de
tourner je parle qui en joue par les
fautes c'est vraiment juste il a t il à
son son plan s'il a sa feuille en disant
ben voilà où plus de 5000 tu sors et
c'est comme ça quoi après on aime pas je
le bouille la 37 % ce qui est aussi
assez faible et après par contre c'est
un joueur qui peut contribuer dans
d'autres secteurs il jouait ailier fort
là pour les panthers qui prostitue 5
rebonds il prend en effet deux passes
décisives par match on voit qu'ils
perdent le ballon le ratio à seat en
over il est globalement un mais on va
voir que
il passe beaucoup mieux que ce que les
chiffres le monde parce qu'il joue quand
même avec des partenaires assez assez
assez faible et que la perte de ballon
sont aussi djoko texte collectif et
après on est à 0,8 du bloc donc voilà un
joueur qui est assez assez complet
on va passer au stade avancé avant
d'aller fort du clip vous n'hésitez pas
si vous avez des question donc pour
regarder ses stats faut descendre un
petit peu le volume de tiers plus faible
s'explique parce qu'il a été blessé
contrairement aux coéquipiers y situe en
ont pris trois fois plus de tirs que lui
lui l'a joué que 8 matches alors que les
autres ils ont joué 15 16 avant sa
blessure c'était le plus gros volume de
tir de l'équipe instant
sans débat possible on voit dans sa
répartition d une répartition
assez assez classique annecy et on a un
quart de ces terres près du panier
efficace à 50% ce qui est correct d'être
excellent on voit par contre derrière où
ils ont passé d'une passe décisive
baldwin doit se créer son propre espace
pour aller au niveau du palier la 30%
prix sur les longs de points avec une
belle efficacité 35% encore une fois
beaucoup de poules up on est sûr
actuellement 40% de tirs près après une
passe décisive et enfin pour le tir à
trois points c'est là quand même la
grosse partie deux de ses tirs et c'est
ça qui pose un peu question et à 34% de
réussite seulement et on est chaude de
tirs pris en catch and shoot et aux
lancers francs au niveau où on voit que
alors il prend pas beaucoup de tirs près
du panier du coup il a peu de lancers
francs et quand il y va ça 14% seulement
quand tu vois lille comme ça tu te dis
quoi sur le jour de son profil un petit
peu
ben je maintenant je l'avais vu jouer
j'avais j'avais un peu regardé avant les
les points pour possession sur synergie
j'ai quand même l'impression que c'est
un c1
comme tu disais c'est un joueur qui est
dans une dans une petite équipe et
pas du coup tu as beaucoup de
responsabilités mais est ce qu'il est
déjà assez fort pour pouvoir jouer
contre des équipes qui le cible il le
cible énormément si t'as pas le tapa le
matos à côté de toi tu vas pourront
quand même pouvoir que relâche un peu de
pression
tu vois faire le choix dans une petite
équipe c'est ses biens si vraiment tu as
le tas le talent pour
trouver des points c'est mieux pour des
mamans des meneurs qui ont plus la balle
en main et qu'ils sont très forts
que des des postes des joueurs qui ont
qui en plus d'un besoin d'avoir un peu
de création de la part des autres quoi
on se rappelle alors je sais pas à quel
point je suis la nba ou pas mais que
diam arendt qui jouait pendant une
petite équipe et me respecte vraiment
ennemis de dieu ils avaient fait une
deuxième année et du coup ils jouaient
toutes les possessions bon moment il
avait explosé à me wade a été on se
poser la question est ce qu'il est
excellent parce qu'ils jouent contre des
adversaires très léger
juge-t-il excellent l'histoire nous dira
que finalement ils épreuve 2e position
de sa draft
du coup en 2018 2019 et qu'en fait
maintenant les all stars avec qui on
considère comme un top 5 e joueur comme
ça que j'aurais à son poste baldwin lui
on va voir qu'il un dribble assez limité
si tu prends là dessus on verra ma
droite magouille c'est ce que j'ai ce
que j'ai vu c'est ce que j'ai vu et je
dois je te rejoins tout à fait sur le
fait que tu vois je pensais à des camps
j'utilisais savant à des curie à delhi
la date est déjà mort hante
battue a déjà cédé meneur de jeu ils ont
beaucoup la balle en main ils peuvent se
créent leur propre tir si tu as besoin
des autres pour créer qui joue avec des
équipiers qui sont un peu que sur les
shoots que j'ai vu il ya quand même des
fois des passes qui sont pas top quoi
dieu doit donc c'est
si tu joues en plus cons des équipes qui
te cible
chaque fois que tu as la balle s'est pas
passé les les pas top t'auras pas 56
ouvert tu vois la joue sur la zone c'est
gentil mais je pense pas que c'est la
meilleure équipe qu'il jouisse taille
non plus n'en regarde moritz en fait
j'ai pris je vous ai clip et pour ceux
qui regardent de match en fait
un match contre eux repartent maurice où
il a fait ne serait parfaite il a tout
rentrait quasiment tous rentrés tous ses
tirs à trois points les amis et je vous
ai mis ensuite le mode contre colorado
qui est une équipe de à aimer d'or avec
le numéro 12 blanc vous allez voir à
l'écran kidiaba walker qui tendent
meilleur un des meilleurs défenseurs du
pays qui l'a collé toute la soirée et il
finit à 1 sur 8 aux tirs vraiment deux
équipes de niveaux différents et de
résultats très très différentes et même
robert moris on va voir le jour
différents clips surtout dans la fin de
la vidéo à la fois ils défendent à 4
contre lui quoi parce qu'ils savent très
bien que c'est le seul joueur qui peut
mettre un tir c'est la seule menace et
ils vont vraiment tout lui fermé tout va
être rabattus sur ce jour là qui du coup
a passé des moments très compliqués du
côté de milwaukee et ce qui est
surprenant c'est que depuis qu'il est
blessé il commence à gagner des matches
ces problématiques ce
après tu disais tu disais aussi vieilli
revenait dans leur conférence donc la
question est aussi suivi bien joué je
peux pas rater les stats avec toi
oui oui je vous conte comme en ce moment
des équipes en gros de leur standing et
ils s'en sortent un petit peu mieux on
va on va pouvoir repasser au au clip sur
le tir alors je vais remettre depuis
depuis le début tout simplement
avant de faire du râle aussi matin j'ai
laissé tomber roy noir du ralenti en
tout cas de se sentir sa mécanique sa
fluidité et ses caisses que qu'est ce
que tu en penses
je trouve que bad et qu'il est dès
qu'ils arrivent à se mettre du rythme il
est
léger mais je trouve que c'est très
fluide vois ça ça monte bien notamment
sur les premiers shoots que tu avais
montré
tu vois c'est c'est quand même bien
coordonner sa paye et que dès qu'ils
arrivent à être envie de croquer une
certaine impression de facilité on
pareil quand il arrivera avant ses fils
a pas forcément une distance tu vois
qu'il arrive la transition un peu d'air
à la balle
s'il a passé à peu près correct tu vois
il il avance il peut il peut facilement
shooté à mettre derrière et c'est pas un
souci pour moi ya pas vraiment de de
croo de gros points faibles tu vois sur
les sur sa mécanique tu sens qu'il a la
balle un peu sur le côté gauche sur le
côté gauche du visage
donc luce lui je pense que voilà comme
disait romain avant il va débattre de ce
que j'ai vu d'ailleurs ils prient sur
une émission sur tout ce qui est cool
pour les choses comme ça au même les
sorties d'écran y tu vois qui est sur la
gauche c'est plutôt bien contre sur la
droite j'aime pas si je l'aï vu une fois
que tu vois pas ce que c'est son corps
est pas forcément
là où il pose place la balle et ses
appuis c'est pas forcément fait pour
aller à droite qu'on
a aucun poulpe à droite en tout cas
d'accord donc tu vois un joueur qui va
être
globalement dans les premières heures
alors là on sait que sa première année
en nba ils font pas trop regardant sur
les choix les roues qui les laisse un
petit peu faire ce qu'ils veulent mais
qui va très rapidement ciblé on a les
donne à détroit et ce qu'elle voir une
consigne est assez clair d'orientation
sur son jeu derrière
or je pense que voilà tu ne sais pas
c'est pas je vais pas dire de bêtises
parce que tu vois
kevin durant s'est quand même c'est un
monstre et que mais j'ai l'impression
que quand il était plus jeune il avait
tendance à plus doit vendre avant de
couleur peau avant de ses shoots là sont
nés 10 notation à trois points il la
faisait beaucoup plus à gauche quoi
d'accord parce qu'il a il a un peu la
balle du même côté côté gauche du visage
ou devant le visage toi et tu
le fais de ma gauche et l'hésitation
d'hésitation main gauche pour se lever
ça semblait beaucoup plus naturelle
après voilà c'est un tel phénomène un
tel monstre de travail que maintenant il
le fait main droite main gauche quoi
mais mais au tout début j'ai
l'impression qu'il était beaucoup plus
accès à gauche et et lui bon c'est pas
laissez pas le même calibre mais
mais au niveau de la wii il pose un peu
sa balle je trouve que c'est il ya des
trucs qu'on assimile de dresser un tente
ensuite il tue 10 kevin durand d'ici là
il a été beaucoup comparé donc à kevin
durant est effectivement mais de façon
plus réaliste à et encore moi je trouve
ça que c'est c'est gentil mais à michael
porter junior je sais pas si tu la situe
à turin pour garder qui joue maintenant
du côté de denver qui est souvent blessé
pour avec des gros problèmes de dos
moi le problème que je vais avoir sur ce
joueur c'est que j'ai l'impression qu'il
va faire qu'une seule chose en nba c'est
ce tir ces tirs à trois points
qui va être utilisé quasiment
exclusivement dans un rôle de peter popp
en fait tu vois je le vois très bien
être une sorte de post 3 postes 4 poser
des écrans pop et est sanctionnée bien
jour de la shoah de la boue tiennent
mais je le vois pas pouvoir se créer
ainsi un bel hommage je ne vois pas être
un joueur qui va sortir dans des
systèmes justement flou qui tu vois en
remontée est tiré et du comptable de
potentialités je suis je suis assez
inquiet sur ses chances de gagner je
vais pas le premier en loterie par
exemple la ville était attendu dans le
top non non mais ouais ouais moi je suis
un peu d'âge un peu d'accord avec toi
après j'ai pas vraiment vu de match en
entier mais tu sens que c'est un plat un
joueur qui à l'heure à qui sait ce qui
c'est ce qui se passe et qui sait se
mettre dans les espaces mais oui c'est
pas le cas je trouve que les deux gars
qui m'a présenté ce soir à chaud ils ont
quand même des similitudes puissant qui
connaissent le connaissent le basket ils
sont sont ils sont elles sont pas
maladroits sans être non plus à 50% à 3
points
c'est pas des gars c'est pas des gars ou
ingénieurs sont bâtis sont tus à la
défense fait pas forcément des impasses
sur les autres enfin et pas forcément
des impasses sur les autres pour les
empêcher de tirer à tout prix quoi tu
vois mes mais ça reste des bons joueurs
adroits et ils peuvent avoir un rôle
comme tu disais un rôle un rôle
spécifique mais c'est pas les gars qui
tu vas donner la balle pour qu'ils
créent pour pour les autres même qui
créé pour eux pour eux pour pour se
chercher un ajoute que c'est ça et
sachant que quand on est chauds de la
loterie en termes de potentiel on va
très souvent il ya des exceptions
évidemment mais on va très souvent pour
ce profil d'ailier là maintenant
valoriser les mecs qui sont capables de
créer leur propre tir et de créer un
décalage là où il a peut-être déçus
patrick ballet junior c'est que correa
était au niveau inférieur au lycée y
avait pas un seul mec de sa taille
quelle est sa mobilité on rappelle il
fait de maître 08 et quand il était au
lycée les mecs qui bougeait globalement
aussi vite qu'elle ne s'était plus des
extérieurs des arrières nous qu'il était
beaucoup plus grand que non qu'il
retient et sur la face en fait
et les mecs qui faisait sa taille il
n'avait pas la capacité à pouvoir le
tenir dans des sorties d'écran et c'est
donc là cette année même si je vous
donne une conférence plus faible à une
réalité qui c'est qui s'est mise que le
dribble et trop et trop léger pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir 2000 et est juste
prendre des tirs sur le museau des
autres il est rentré avec une belle
efficacité
par
va regarder le haut niveau alors je
n'aurai pas tous et les faces allure le
sel installe toi tranquille où elle
passe à patrick baldwin junior on va se
mettre aux géomètres et les clips au
ralenti un petit peu au niveau du tir si
tu as des observations ou tu vois des
stops des frises à me dire tu me dis et
puis on inventera tranquillement là
dessus surtout pour voir s'il ya un
écart entre moment où il rate son tir et
moment il me soutient as tu vois moi
j'ai fait ce que j'avais remarqué avancé
que j'aimais bien quand la balle elle
venait de sa droite il a l'impression
qu'il a il a un peu l'habitude de ça ils
se mobilisent mais bien en rythme
après voilà comme tu disais l'acei chute
sur un an ils shootent sur un mineur
il est fait de mes tweets la vie est
quand même assez mal elle par d'assez
haut donc au final quand il peut mettre
là tu as même s'il a passé n'est pas
parfaite le fait d'ouvrir ses appuis
puis de le remettre vers le cercle ça le
l'obligent à se donner du rythme tu vois
là il me semble aussi parler tu vois là
elle vient de la droite tu as il a
toujours ce petit moment et quand il
arrive à faire ça il enchaîne bien c'est
très très fluide par la suite au niveau
des pieds ce que tu trouves alors je me
dis est ce que les pieds partent pas un
peu trop en avant sur la retombée ce cas
pas un risque là dessus de
déséquilibrer de blessure derrière nous
ça te semble correct dans la zone choc
pauvres ok alors moi ce que j'ai bien
sûr c'est que 10 places et ya un petit
rat stultz j'aime bien toujours les gars
qui qui peuvent un petit peu salée leurs
adversaires donc là il se retourne avant
que la balle à l'encontre il parce qu'il
ait joué nos jours il est en feu il
prendra une petite faute mais la clé
fini à 8 sur 8 à trois points je crois
non c'est sur six en première mi temps
et après finira je crois à 8 sur 10 à
trois points chauds
sur le match
mais après tu as là c'est quand même et
tu vois que l'équipe en face est pas
c'est pas la mer et qui peut initier et
c'est clair sur la zone sur la zone il
est quand même souvent tout seul dans
l'eau mais qui là il est à 8 sur 8 mai
le il continue à laisser shooter
assekrem manque un peu de la datation et
bien je pense qu'ils voulaient lui faire
plaisir pour qui c'était un des premiers
matches où il était diffusé il se dit
vasile bri était là pour ça et là sur se
voir un chèque là tu vas sur l'idée
qu'il est convoité par at c à barrie
walker ici le numéro 12 qui est un
ailier qui défendront n'diaye et tu vois
niveau des pieds je trouve que
maintenant ils ratent les pieds pas
beaucoup plus en avril beaucoup plus en
déséquilibre badella là je pense qu'il
sort d'un écran il est quand même tu
vois il a un peu derrière la ligne quand
même
et je pense n'est pas impossible si tu
vois toute l'année tu t'entraînes contre
une équipe d'une conférence
conférence inférieure et la boum tu
joues contre un gars qui est tu me dis
que c'est un gros défenseur on n 6 et tu
sors d'un écran tapas le pique d'être
contestés comme ça une distance tu dois
un peu plus poussée et la voie que c'est
quand même beaucoup moins fluide
qu'avant c'est sa roma il nous dit dans
le midi dans le chatt pied vers l'avant
il ya une rotation de la hanche et de l'
axe droit sûrement pour compenser un
petit manque sur la poussée sur le
gainage
ouais c'est aussi parce que quand il est
quand il a du rythme il a il il n'a pas
besoin de compenser en fait tu vois
c'est fluide là quand tu es cote a
besoin de pousser bah c'est sûr que tu
tu va plus chercher un peu la jambe
souvent ça te permet de dalé d'aller
d'aller à l'échoppé ces
dernières petit poucet qui permet de
gagner un peu de distance mais mais là
pour moi mon avis là c'est pas un shoot
qui maîtrise face à un défenseur
enfin entre un défenseur comme ça où je
n'ai pas en tout cas je n'ai pas vu
beaucoup faire face à quoi ils
emprunteraient très bon ça que tu vois
je te disais tout à l'heure quand je me
fais des projections je ne voyais pas
train mais qui sortent des écrans et qui
qu'ils prennent des tirs comme ça
vraiment à la entre guillemets dj
riddick est plus sur une situation où il
va vraiment posé le screen et ensuite
pop et et est serré où il ya vraiment
moins de rotation à faire moins de
décalage à faire
a dit fort
accent sur trois voitures à peu près le
même style 2d marca je crois avec un une
conclusion une conclusion similaire
encore une fois on est chauds de la
course en sortie d'écran alors en plus
il est pas il n'a pas prié d'être un
athlète explosif
pour pouvoir m'en prendre de vitesse la
l'écran et les je vais je vais me dire
il était classe de la part de son pivot
il a pas de décalage si son credo
finalement surtout va prendre un peu
souple et encore une fois c'est pas
quelque chose dans lequel il va être à
l'aise ce se retourner comme ça après
une course et et prendre le tir
et tu vois même cottin la droite comme
ça je trouve le rythme il n'est pas trop
mal encore à près de ces îlots web c'est
comme dit je pense qu'il n'a pas
l'habitude mais c'était quand même mieux
qu'avant c'était quand même plus vite
que celui qu'il a pris juste avant que
tu le trouve plus après tu vois
tu vois c'est tout est fait sur le même
rythme
dommage dommage pour lui son pivot il
m'a pas un écran parce que même là des
français les fin tu vois c'est payet à
aucun moment il est contesté car son
équipe a su c'est pas super bien c'est
pas super bien défendu non plus mais
je suis là du coup je te jure mais
plusieurs faons donc là
ouais et encore tu as une petite
adaptation qui l'a souvent
ce petit geste où il s'arrête et après
il a eu
les deux tu as de biens bien rentrer
dans la balle
il a tendance à dire oui les seuls à
laisser la balle venir vers lui quoi
avec comme on m'a dit qu'il n'y a pas de
changement de rythme c'est après il est
aussi grand en 2008 voilà mais
qu'ils changent pas trop de rythme et et
si la défense paraît il c'est un peu le
site est un peu
embrouillé là-bas à l'opposé il n'a pas
trop qui des rongeurs qui met du coup
après là il perd le rythme à la fin sur
le petit parking
donc là on va toujours du che repris aux
transitions quelque chose avec lequel il
est très à l'aise dans sa matière très
nba quelque chose que tu faisais ya dix
ans tu te faisait sentir tout de suite
lui là dessus il n'y a aucun souci la
trappe en transition et il s'élève alors
il a avec une femme et des sites a été
faible sur ce tir là les gens se massent
à y rentrer et où tu trouves que dans la
proche et tu vas y à pas le petit la
petite hésitation quoi ils rentrent
vraiment dans la balance et là
tu vois qu'il est tout le temps à lancer
un souvent là sur la sur la transit là
quand il arrive un trailer je trouve
c'est qui lui convient bien quoi tu as
eu la double attend un peu derrière et
quand il voit la balle arrive et il a
tendance à aller vers l'avant c'est
autre chose que je continue à sortir
d'un écran et au final tu es sur une
course plutôt en recul en quoi
l'appareil quoi et ça je la remise fasse
encore une fois colorado en transition
il est loin on voit là maurice wiss
élèves il est loin derrière la ligne
mais mme pauline biais là motel et
rapide est complètement ouverte chabaab
et walker ici a voulu que le 12 a voulu
surcharger la protection delà du cercle
et donc ils se retrouvent avec un tir
complètement ouvert
et ça fait filoche
alors ici j'ai mis quelque chose
on l'a peu vu fermer
ceux qui veulent le comparer à michael
potter du nord c'est à qui vont aller
rechercher cette capacité à se créer son
propre tir dans le dribble donc ici on a
vraiment eu un petit dribble avec un
ministère bakelants globalement pour se
créer un décalage je me dis ce que tu en
penses moi je trouve qu'il ya un vrai
décalage de créer
c'est pas explosif non plus
non après je sais pas enfin malgré
pourtant juniors c'est quand même
un très bon joueur quoi oui oui
je je je vois là je vois je vois ce que
les gens il veut le dire un peu dans le
rôle 3 4
tu vois c'est mais de là là tu as même
même s'il le mais
tu vois je trouve seif est moins fluide
quand il ay là il parlant c'est quoi
[Musique]
allez allez elle est nue ça me plait
humblement à redire mais après voilà ça
reste un shoot c'est sa chute difficile
quand l on apprend vraiment de quoi
vraiment de baser sur un
sur sur un shoot comme ça pour voir s'il
a vraiment les capteurs seront bien sûr
on va te le truc c'est que comme ils
l'on prend très très peu
un clip est derrière tu vois quoi tu
recherches d'arrière des actions en plus
c'est une équipe qui est très très plus
diffusés pour mon plus grand plaisir
alors je t'avoue que je me dis même
punition de milwaukee je pleure
intérieurement parce que c'est
dégueulasse à regarder
il n'y a pas beaucoup de matchs de
disponible donc tu finis très vite par
tourner en rond donc j'en ai cinq si ce
que j'ai pu voir et ce jour de
démarquage balle en main on en voit on
n'en voit plus en mi distance que qu'à
trois points
alors dans le ciel qui le dit très bien
apprise d'impulsion et romain qui nous
dit
tout alors parce que ouais kaka nous dit
sur les 4 chaînes shoot entendu d'écran
laid je ne souffre quasiment jamais
tourné vers le cercle et roma qui dit en
cloud alignés c'est pas trop grave faute
en pense quoi de sa
non moi je suis plus je suis plutôt
d'accord un tueur les sur les notamment
que ce soit les sorties d'écran sur les
sur les comment dire sur les mêmes sur
les poster sur les feuilles des
temps que tant que
banque à la fin
on va dire tonton bus tournant premier
et après tes jambes derrière tourne
ensuite et tu finis un peu par le pied
en avant pour te rééquilibrer
fin tu vois moi pour ceux qui
connaissent david andersen quelqu'un qui
j'ai joué à l'asvel qui a joué en nba en
euroligue quand il m'expliquer un peu
sur les sur les feuilles de route sur le
post up et bah quand il tournait ses
pieds ses genoux étaient alignés vallat
vers le ver le corner quoi tu vois vers
le corner qui est quand même pas du tout
en ligne avec le panier et donc ils
sauter il sautait comme ça et c est
pourtant c'était pas un énorme athlète
mais c'est que après ou le donc le haut
tourné en premier et les jambes tourné
vers la fin et donc pour moi sur une
sortie d'écran avec une course comme ça
qui est quand même voilà qui prend du
gaz tu es quand même très dur de réussir
à mettet à mettre tes jambes tout de
suite vers le panier
donc ouais je pense que tu tournes
d'abord les épaules sur le shoot et
aline le reste ensuite que la traduction
de temps et finalement la feinte et qui
dit peuvent être derrière ben final
c'est ouais c
c'est comme si ces deux temps mais comme
celui-ci tu le fais bien c'est plus en
un mouvement quoi ouais ouais c'est sûr
de la fluidité je rage est comme ça ok
ici on a un deuxième tir qui est cette
fois ci mais encore pris du coup dans le
dribble et cette fois ci c'est un échec
et on revoit finalement à peu près la
même mécanique sauf que ça c'est fini ça
rentre pas et le tir est très très court
en face de jabbar et walker justement
cette hésitation
et puis l'élévation
mais on voit tu vois même quand ils
retombent à la réception que il a pas du
tout confiance on se tire là
là là je pense qu'il voit depuis le
début que ça va être compliqué vous prêt
parce qu'il n'a pas la capacité
alors volcker pas surtout que c'est un
gag de m huit de mes tweets et comme tu
disais henry school ils devaient être
plus long que tout le monde donc la
faire se tirent là le tir là quand tu
que tu le fais sur un mineur ou tu le
fais sur un mec qui est qui est long
comme ça avec un long bras devant toi
même si je trouve que tu as le défenseur
y
patiner dans une pression mais au final
tu vois il a le sur l'autre si bien le
timing du shooter oui je suis de mettre
la main et si t'as pas l'habitude de de
faire ça contre ce genre de compte ce
genre de gars qui est qui est aussi long
que toi et ben c'est vite et troublée
quoi ouais c'est clair c'est que la
version qui nous dit il ne touche
absolument aucun espace à voir des
guenot n'y a pas d'espèces de crêpa
scapa d'explosivité que walker il est
long qui sait très bien qui peut pas
partir en dribble en plus le spécifie
les pas bons on regarde de haut niveau
du tiers- prix en fait c'est très très
peu d espace pour lui et qui va se faire
qui va se tenir latéralement d'être de
côté donc ce tyran passe et plus il ne
fait une dernière option je sais tout ce
qui lui reste et il le monde ne le
montrent pas il nous dit qu elle
commence à poser ses dribbles tu as
l'impression qu'il sait déjà que ce qui
le fait qu'il va tirer j'aime pas du
tout ça mais moi non plus moi non plus
un genre qui est très limité donc je ne
vois pas du tout avoir le droit rien que
le droit de prendre sur deux tirs au
niveau supérieur ce sera vraiment pour
moi mes yeux cleanser de bout de chaîne
et c'est pour ça que que par rapport à
certains manquent d'envergure qui loue
déjà un peu baissé moi je le baseball
donc la voiture des laitières du coup
dans la zone alors y'a pas une grosse
contestation des tiers moi ce que j'aime
bien cette fluidité par contre à pouvoir
rattraper tout de suite su retourner
tout de suite remonter quelque chose qui
avait prêté demander beaucoup alors pas
le même profil un iphone c'est on lui
demande et boucles de la zone à
tennessee de pouvoir marquer là dessus
et l'a jamais été très très fier on voit
que naturellement
il s'est entraîné quoi
ouais ouais tu sens que c'est là selon
la zone à stefan
et stefan aust et son shoot quoi
ouais tu vas y et l'exécution elle est
rapide à l'efi alors il rate quelques
uns ce que tu trouves contre peu
entre eux il ya un écart entre le tiers
qui méchant cette zone et le tir qui
rate sur deux situations complètement
identique
non non moi je veux ça mais ça m'a pas
mal ça m'a pas marqué tu vois je trouve
qu'il est toujours mieux quand il tourne
avec eux mais même situation mais là il
aurait cherché non il y en a deux le
même la lituanie le loupé une fois mais
je crois qu'il en est un aussi ouais
ouais d'autres tournées sur l'épaule
gauche je pense que comme je disais
avant il a plus un show talent et
l'épaule droite même si là il va aussi
loupé tu vois mais bon là c'est toi
c'est un shoot tâche est trop long ça
tape juste derrière c'était plutôt droit
donc des fois faut pas se prendre la
tête parce que c'est loupé ouais ouais
on peut pas on peut pas les mettre tous
ces pas c'est pas ça m'a dit hier au
niveau des lancers francs
alors j'essaie d'avoir des angles on l'a
souvent de phase 2a en z et avec des
réussites et des ratés
moi j'aime plutôt tu vois c'est cela ce
qui me fait dire qu'il doit bien aimé
kevin durant et parce que ces petits
mouvements de bras qui fait avec
l'épaule devrait se relâcher
ouais c'est quelque chose que moi je
fais aussi maintenant
parce que depuis quinze jours j'ai fait
j'ai fait un énorme et un bol parce que
je me trompe on m'a touché le nerf du
coude juste à pavant et tu vois j'ai
c'est quelque chose que je fais pour
relâcher au cas où est ce que j'avais vu
kevin durand de faire et je trouve ça
très intéressant sur son geste
l'entraînement je trouve ça très je
trouve ça fluide donc je vois qu'il a là
tu veux tu vois bien agencé de face qui
met la balle un peu plus de vent devant
ses yeux devant vers la gauche c'est pas
quelque chose dont je suis forcément fan
mais honnêtement il ay là il a quand
même un beau fouetter sa main gauche
elle est quand même et quand même bien
en place on va dire voilà au niveau des
bases c'est quand même c'est comme
solides qu'au hockey est pareil sur les
sur les shows de celui qui va rater est
ce que tu vois un décalage ou c'est
vraiment juste à temps mais non non non
non je tue voici maintenant d'en sortir
il y avait quelque chose à je vois la
main gauche il est quand même belle le
mouvement du poignet des biens 74% donc
après c'est soit au niveau du du volume
si on n'a pas trop ou alors après des
fois tu peux avoir un très beau geste
était mentalement mentalement on en a
loupé quelques uns et ça commence à
torturer l'esprit quoi il avait commencé
la saison avec 25 % à 3 points donc il
vérifiait vraiment un très mauvais début
de saison et tu vois que ça va pas quoi
donc je trouve ça un côté psychologique
c'est important parce que notre
championnat u19 je reviendrai fille les
stats mais il échoue une plus belle
efficacité dans tous les domaines
ça me donne pas on à pierre qui nous
demandent dans le dans le chatt nicolas
pour un jeune joueur estampillé shooter
qu'est ce que le staff de développement
de cibler la sélection de tirs les
différents types de tir développé son
jeu balle en main
bah déjà je pense que
sélection de shoots non je pense que
quand tu es jeune faut vraiment des
vraiment réussir à
t'entraîner sûr on va dire tous les
toutous les tous les types de shoot même
site et te dit je te dit quelque chose
enfin une bêtise cité des
coachs voile à l'école d'un jeune joueur
aimé tutu compte pas le faire je vous ai
dit c'est pas parce que tu as peut-être
des parce que tu as peut-être des
joueurs qui sont meilleurs que lui sur
pick'n roll c'est pas pour autant qu'il
faut pas en dehors des entraînements lui
apprendre à lui apprendre à shooter
derrière un écran enfin derrière un pic
c'est a pas trop de ce tiger dans un
deal faut quand même lui apprendre à
utiliser les styger et avant de passer
sur des
shoots de match comme ça avant toute
chose pour moi c'est voter jeunes c'est
une fois que tu as les bonnes bases
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
répétitions quoi
moi je considère vraiment ça en trois
temps quand tu es très jeune c'est et si
les bases avant toute chose essayer
d'avoir le moins de mauvaises habitudes
possible de construire des bonnes bases
après une fois que tu as les bases c'est
beaucoup de beaucoup de spots up pour
mais quand je dis beaucoup c'est
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup pour que
voilà c'est basé leur entrée que ça
devienne une seconde nature et que tu as
plus besoin de réfléchir à comment tu
mets ta main sur la balle à comment
voilà toutes ces choses là et ensuite tu
passes sur des sur décision des
situations de match où pareil tu essaies
d'en faire beaucoup en étant en étant
parfait en réfléchissant à ce que tu
fais pour que pareils c'est devenu une
seconde nature et après côté un peu plus
vieux comme moi il est battu moi moi je
suis passé sur une routine beaucoup plus
courtes ou jeu à préserver de l'énergie
pour les matches et maintenant j'ai fait
j'ai vraiment que que mais que mme
situations de match ont à dire
donc assez ferrata sont alors quand tu
dis un gros volume pour qu'on se rende
compte à peu près sur un entraînement
par exemple classique
à voir en moyenne tu vois tu prend
combien de terre d'une même situation
pour créer vraiment inhabituel mécanique
à quoi j'étais plus jeune
chez que la base je venais minimum je
pense une heure une heure et demie avant
chaque entraînement et je partais
minimum une heure après quoi donc et on
shoote est bon shooter pas par deux
teintes et avait pas encore tous mais
tous qui a maintenant tu as des fois
dans les équipes tu as des coachs un dvd
coach individuel à des assistants qui
peuvent aider nous tu avais un coach un
coach en assistant donc au final quand
il voulait faire tout ça tu faisais tu
faisais tu échoues tu veux et tu échoues
de tout seul mais bon après maintenant
tu as quand même pas mal de matos tu as
des menottes a quand même des hoops
factory des trucs comme ça c'est le cas
où vous êtes a pas de salle
donc il n'y a pas forcément de nombre
précis mais voilà quand tu es jeune tu
peux envoyer des milliers et des
milliers de shoot 1 c'est normal face et
c'est ce qu'il faut je pense ouais ouais
tu seras décrocher moi j'ai pas mal tu
vois là vous travaillé des années
toutefois
les sro league parce que bon c'est les
anciens font aujourd'hui j'ai tiré 100
fois et vu diba multiplient oui soit et
ça sent c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vraiment pas beaucoup en effet
déjà au bout deux centimes à quelle
heure bras qui pourrit les tweets jeudi
va vous attendez vous à des taux début
c'est pas exactement ça
d'habitude après tu prends et puis tu
t'y penses même plus tu sens même plus
puis c'est comme ça que ça rentre c'est
clair moi j'ai toujours trouvé ça
de répétition
ça c'était pour ça c'était pour le tir
on va regarder du coup rapidement
le reste alors on va commencer par tout
ce qui va être là de l'attak balle en
main et parce que je suis un peu rincé à
l'eau j'ai commencé directement par les
gros défaut c'est qu'en fait on voit
qu'il peut pas partir en dribble qu'à
partir du moment où il ya qu'on lui
bloque une direction qu'on lui met un
premier contact comme sur le premier
clip qu'on va voir ici et finalement
hispaniques sont les tripes s'arrête et
qui va devoir transmettre transmettre
rapidement le ballon et c'est pas
quelque chose soit laquelle il va être
du tout à l'aise et qu'il ait la
capacité à changer de rythme donc c'est
à dire soit allonger la longue date son
dribble soit pouvoir accélérer été serré
balle en main pour pouvoir changer de
main tout simplement pour pouvoir casser
cassez cassez ligne et crée un espace
avec son défenseur direct il ya un
capable de faire et que dès que tu
n'envoies sur sa main gauche il va être
en élévation directement il va même pas
essayer d'aller jusqu'au niveau du
panier là on le voit choix de la main
droite les tenues il est contesté par un
pivot latéralement alors il trouve une
photo à la fin
tant mieux pour lui on voit qu'un pivot
n 6 et qui sera pas un jour une bille
arrive déjà le maintenir au contact quoi
ouais je vois même sur les 110 d'écran
il n'y a pas vraiment de changement de
rythme de cuisson qui l'a pas
je sais pas si les conseils comme ingres
aux athlètes ou pas mais ça a pas l'air
après je pense qu'il va encore se
développer en assurant il a et je pense
qu'il peut encore quand même se
développer parce que comme tu utilisais
86 kg de m 8 il peut et je pense qu'il
peut quand même encore prendre dès
maintenant tu sais avec tous les moyens
qu'ils ont pour bosser mais même
physiquement tu peux quand même encore
quand progresser comme moi je le vois
bien prendre en masse tu vas devenir
vraiment beaucoup plus volumineux
pouvoir mettre de l'impact peut-être tu
vas pour pouvoir terminer par contre
petit toutes les situations de dribbles
vraiment je crois pas du tout je crois
pas non mais je pense que je sais c'est
pas qu'on va lui demander non bio enfin
c'est ce qu'on attendait de lui quand il
sortait du lycée mais moi j'ai très faim
quand je les ai vus avec l'équipe
américaine jeunes me suis tu te dis pas
ce gars il a nié les capacités
athlétiques ni les skills des dribbles
pour pouvoir les truites menace au
niveau supérieur comme un finisseur de
boues tiennent là on le voit il va se
faire donc pick and roll où il est
porteur de balle et un switch il est
défendu par oscar silva le frère de ah
j'oubliais le nom de son grand frère qui
maintenant je joue maintenant jaune
allemagne qui est pas un dans ma tête
qui est pas un grand défenseur mais qui
va juste pour aller mettre un peu de
pression sur le ballon et tout de suite
à une perte de balle quoi voilà quand
ils ont cassé la situation d' attaque
tout simplement ce qu'ils ont dû bruit
derrière t'inquiète pas c'est juste que
j'ai trois chats qui vont décider de me
détruire pas de souci
là est ce que j'aime bien avec ce jour
là par contre c'est qu'il ya des vraies
qualités de passe alors comme il joue
avec des pitres
bas du cou et derrière y'a pas de
réussite mais tu vois dans dé bonnes
situations là la passe donc correctement
elle va être mise dans le corner il ya
une belle lecture de jeu
ça aura une plaie pour y avoir ficelles
et la passe d'après être millet en
milieu des dispositions bien dans la aux
nichons un flotteur donc je me trompe et
dans le monde des clips dont l'auteur un
petit touchés on va avoir pas mal de
situations de post il va très rapidement
transmettre
rapidement transactions qu'ils ont et
qui sait quand même nature et il sait se
placer dans les espaces après donc
égalisé dans le chat avant
le pause sur la zone en nba après avoir
beaucoup donc mais tu vois qui s'est
quand même
si c'est quand même bouger il s'est
quand même là il s'est quand même passé
la balle mais c'est quand tu joues avec
voilà tu peux donner la balle aux mecs
si la prairie
[Musique]
ou même avant gaiman rballefin tu vois
donc
sa parole quand tu fais le choix de la
lande une petite fac pour avoir des
responsabilités c'est sûr que c'est pas
par là où il faut devenir vraiment un
playmaker il faire jouer tout le monde
lui être meilleur meilleur
individuellement et faire briller t te
faire briller toi même coup cette fois
dans le rôle de ce corps là ce que
j'avais à dire sur les klitsckho
jeffries et c'est que
ça tuerait on a des flashs on a parlé de
flash qui n'est jamais on se prend pour
des pokémon
maintenant on a des flashs de passe où
tu te dis ça au niveau supérieur de la
transition dans un rôle de passeur
fonctionnel il pourra toujours rendre un
collectif meilleur donc lâché une
situation nos quais fectivement elle est
dans la zone il au milieu dans le point
faible est là tout de suite la petite
transmis sur la bonne ce poste pour
pouvoir trouver son intérieur qui n'a
rien ne peut pas finir mais cette
capacité manipulation visuel on voit pas
du tout la passe elle va venir là en
tout cas le défenseur ne le vois pas du
tout où il va transmettre rapidement et
efficacement
capable de passer du coup directement
mais aussi pas son rebond comme ça
là ici de trouver le kick électronique
c'est un clip voilà que j'avais doublé
taylor qui aurait dû être à ce niveau là
il encore une fois dans la place d'angel
la balle à lui reste pas bloqué dans les
mains quoi elle ne prend pas dix ans
pour prendre une décision rapidement
quand il touche le ballon il est capable
de transmettre soit de façon
fonctionnelle ou là où il doit le
relever en matière soit pour un joueur
ouvert comme on peut le voir plusieurs
fois malgré les airs ball dramatique de
ses coéquipiers derrière
ouais c'est un des aînés s'est rebâti
voile du sur le dernier clip ben je
crois que je suis là voilà j'ai coupé
avant de voir leur état du tir parce que
c'est encore une brique et que ça me
fatigue et donc j'ai dit bon bah vas-y
je sais ce qui se passe c'est une brique
tu vois air ball essuie la scène briques
aussi
donc on a coupé avant que ça aille
jusqu'au bout
sur le clip suivant ce que je veux
montrer alors je crois que c'est
celui-là je le remets au cas où pour moi
c'est son problème de wet d'explosivité
verticale donc là il va kyoto niveau du
panier mais tu vois il monte pas du tout
alors effectivement il ya une faute qui
se fait bien il sait bien le sabre et au
niveau du bras mais il ya un problème de
niveau de l'athlète sera pas une menace
verticale haut niveau au niveau
supérieur
on
peut pas explosif dans la campagne et
paniers pas explosif latéralement pas
explosif verticalement on est sûr quand
même un athlète très moyen et pourtant
il n'est pas lourd malgré la taille sur
le clip suivant va voir du rebond
défensif parce que j'aime a par contre
une fois on a dit qu'il était à 6,5
robot c'est qu'ils protègent bien ça sa
prise de position rebonds et du bac
saout sécurisé c'est quelque chose
d'intelligent qui les rendra toujours
une valeur positive dans un collectif
encore une fois la prise de position
alors l'eurobond il est long et en
échange du peuple de ce goût rue daunou
voilà c'est pas un bloc hyper explosif
c'est juste un bon placement intelligent
et capable de faire le bon choix
c'est pas les dommages qui joue avec un
mec qui sait ça regarde le tu vas voir y
en a un qui arrive juste après
j'ai appelé ça je crois coéquipiers
médiocre à la fin de la transition là tu
l'as où les yeux normalement avec le
numéro 24 alors qu'ils auraient pu lui
fournir le bâlois qui rate son lait yop
derrière
à la de toute beauté
mais ça
attendez laquelle je n'ai pas vu tu la
prends tu l'as pas vu alors autant je te
l'art mais je vais frisé dessus
peut-être celle là dont tu me parler
qu'en fait on a un petit décalage entre
moi parce que je suis passé sur le
stream pour voir où on en était c'est
celle là alors à temps
ah oui c'est tellement de la croix
quel est alors sonné ralentit donc le
gagner tout seul et en plus il rate et
l'élève derrière donc là on est sur la
transition il ya en avançant plus
toujours en avance toujours en avance
toujours en avance trop tard trop tard
qui s'est retiré dans le vieux donc
comment s'appelle le film drôle de
superman où il ya la tempête études et
qui peut encore le sauver il peut encore
le sommeil pour quand le soleil est là
c'est trop tard ah c'est ça c'est ça
et là ce que j'aimerais montrer avec ses
clips là c'est comment la défense et les
focus sur lui quoi c'est on voit que
c'est vraiment le centre de gravité et
dès qu'ils récupèrent le ballon tout de
suite la défense tu voyages à trois
défenseurs qui sont directement projeter
sur lui parce que c'est la seule menace
est donc ça explique ces pourcentages
très très faible on le voit il préfère
faire l'impasse sur tous les autres
tireurs et on va l'avoir situations
suivantes y ait dans le corner à droite
il va récupérer ballon et toute la
défense toute la zone va directement se
concentrer sur lui
tu voyais à l'oeil a vraiment trois
défenseurs qui sont rien directement
dessus et le pauvre ne peut rien faire
voilà voilà voilà voilà
et on a fait le tour du cou de monsieur
baldwin juniors donc en résumé
on en achète le tir on pense que ça peut
être attirant fiable au niveau supérieur
un tireur de finition un tireur de
transition
certainement pas un mec qui va pouvoir
prendre le ballon et se crée son propre
décalage pour prendre pour prendre un
poulpe
pas non plus un mec qui va dans des
courses comme pouvait le faire kalkhoven
mais un mec de sa taille comparaison
peut penser à un tout mcdermott par
exemple qui fait très bien ça alors que
lui non
et du coup en terme de valeur au temple
de projection moi je les verts davies
bertone c'est bien la comparaison
puisque tu en pense et je les verts la
20e 25e place pour l'instant
berlin washington oui exactement la
version 2019 2020 qui tirer correctement
bah ouais tu m'étonnes maintenant il a
pris le cheikh lô que il a plus aucune
raison de faire des efforts bon après
vertes contrées niveau shoot c'est quand
même au dessus bois ouais aulas lui ce
qui me fait douter un peu c'est que je
pense qu'il est passé spécialistes
parce que
tu vois il dire et
c'est bien mais il n'y a pas vraiment un
truc tu vas me battu 34 34 % à 3 points
et enfin
tu vois personne dessus mais en initier
à l'époque c'est pas 34% guidère
[Musique]
wayne bertone sont pas ce serait la
version au principal de de lui même s'il
ya une fluidité mécanique
beaucoup plus et ça pour sembler a
peut-être que vous êtes du rien à
personne alors encore une fois qui est
un vrai spécialiste mais au niveau nba
ou alors attention nikola mirotic ch
époque chicago bulls donc papa la
superstar m vipitude du barça mais le
mec au foot est vraiment temps du pick n
pop et dans la transition trois points
uniquement quoi
wake forest qui du coup qui prennent un
gabarit quoi
qu'ils prennent avec qui prennent le
gabarit est pareil que
écoeuré que lui je pense qu'il est
vraiment pesé spécialisée dans
dans un rôle
dans un rôle de shooteur et du coup qui
progresse là dedans quoi parce que qu'on
parlait imbert imbert times ou même un
miro tiges quand ça sort des écrans
c'est peu et c'est beaucoup plus
solide quoi
on a très clairement qu à qui le dit
mais aux tissus après un bon régime
quand même à l'époque il était déjà
solide vois je me rappelle d'un mec qui
était quand même assez fin mai
nous dit bobby portis s'en souvient bas
bobby portis qui lui avait mis la patte
atteint
ça c'étaient les bonnes relations de
vestiaire eux comme on les apprécie
en attendant bobby portis est champion
nba nicolas nioro teach pas encore
voilà bon bah non le nom de cette si
vous avez des des petites questions je
voulais je remballe nous mêmes choix
christie ou au point nicolas directement
vous n'hésitez pas et puis sinon on va
tranquillement
tranquillement accroché je t'avais je
t'avais dit à peu près une deux heures
on est presque vous dans le thé me
répond c'est pas trop trop elle va
chanter sans se faire voir match
dimanche mais finalement c'est annulé
donc pourquoi tu mangeras jolly j'étais
cassé à temps de récupération ça va je
veux pas être responsable
moi je me retrouve sur les commentaires
lnd point thivillon tel
d'un tricheur qui fait qu'un suiveur
là c'est le capital du csp limoges n'est
pas un rythme
non bah écoute à la fois deux fois on va
on n'a pas en amont n'a pas n'a pas
question dans le no le tchad de quoi
pouvoir tranquillement raccrocher
accrocher nos clips et puis te laisse te
reposer sur un week-end bien mérité
avant k'tu reprennent demain du coup à
l'entraînement quinze mille âmes il tire
du coup pour faire l'exemple par rapport
aux petits jeunes dimanche dimanche
dimanche d'ailleurs est ce que tu as
dans ton équipe a
désormais je suis trop vieux maintenant
c'est bon c'est terminé est ce que ta
jeunesse urd entre l'équipe que tu que
tu voudrais nous le concept surveiller
comme ça qu'elle tu crois ou même dans
le championnat un gars que tu as vu un
petit jeune qui t'a apprécié au nez et
dont on parle pas forcément beaucoup et
dans lequel tu as beaucoup des sports
soit un
nombre à ce seul et je je je je suis pas
mal après j'ai pas encore vraiment
regardé le match mais je connais depuis
longtemps c'est le fils à stephano lâché
il ya la jeune bien sûr c'est moi je les
colle quand j'étais à chalon les joies
que j'ai je vais enfin jp espoir et ma
première année pro c'est la dernière
année de stéphane ans en tant qu' en
tant que basketteur professionnel donc
quand on est toujours restés en contact
et j'ai vu son fils j'ai vu son fils
grandir mais voilà au sens pas donc
prenant prendre en taille sans vraiment
l'avoir jamais vu jouer et là je j'en
attends beaucoup de beaucoup beaucoup de
bien et tu commences à le voir sur le
terrain et tout donc c'est patrick
inquiet qui est très intéressant donc
est vrai un jour pourquoi pas peut être
un petit truc sur lui voir ce que ça
donne quoi alors mike schmidt chouaki
match n'est ce pas oui ma chemise c'est
très très fan de risa chez moi j'ai vu
les combattants du j'ai la chance de
voir lors du match espoirs contre contré
paris basket quand l'asvel est venue à
paris et c'est un actuel me rappelle pas
mal ma christine
c'est un joli être très intelligent qui
bouge très bien des jalons un vrai un
vrai geste armand je suis pas
spécialiste en au niveau du tir mais il
était assez agréable de le voir garder
s'était passé sur un parquet
j'aime bien son sa compréhension du jeu
s'est passé que c'est et je vais
surveiller forcément la prison gabarit
un peu au départ parce qu'il est quand
même fin mais il est très très jeune le
dribble même si je pense pas quand on
aura forcément là dessus au niveau
supérieur et puis les qualités
athlétiques au global mais mais moi je
suis d'accord vise à chasser on va le
surveiller très très fort et c'est
vraiment du plaisir à regarder
yes bank les
intrigues une agrafe grave y'a peut-être
qu'il va falloir manger beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup mieux
rapporté fluidité sympa donc bien aussi
qu'ils
pierre il parle beaucoup de régimes j'ai
vraiment fier pierre est ce que tu as
attendu
non plus moi bien je devais il est
affûté
justice je dis pas de bêtises perdu du
coach en plus il dit complexe soit il a
un complexe et ça
donc non non c'est
comme tous les toujours tous les évêques
d'envergure et lille et il est forcément
sur un régime draconien base de deux
clips de match insupportable à regarder
les uns et les autres et de beaucoup
d'énergie mise donc ça te ça te fait
perdre énormément de calories
non mais bon bah écoute merci à toi en
tout cas d'avoir d'avoir été là c'était
hyper cool de d'avoir regardé du basket
vient au site et des yeux avec ton avis
le jury par constructif et qui j'écris
coûte j'espère que le l'expérience
d'affluer on pourra qu'on pourra faire
sa une autre fois j'en ai d'autres os
d'autres joueurs et puis on va société à
tous une bonne soirée prenez soin de
vous surtout surtout en ce moment
n'hésitez pas
faire des retours sur twitter sur lui
dans les commentaires et tout et puis
aussi à tout bientôt pour du nouveau
contenu envergure et des bisous à tout
le monde bonne soirée voilà prochaine
tiens merci beaucoup